already
okay I think we're live looks like we're
live ladies and gentlemen you know what
to do when we first go live we need you
to leave a like first of all that would
be great go ahead leave a like and then
on top of that too tell us if you can
actually hear us that's a very very
important thing
what's going on John just making sure
that the text is not running off the
side of the screen ah yes aesthetic so
people can see we're live okay I saw the
first one
thinking about the playback here one
second guys I'm gonna make them a little
adjustment okay make a minor minor
adjustment here this needs to be a tad
bigger I understand John's concern don't
worry John I got us covered even though
I'm going to minimize this in a tiny bit
we don't matter it's okay
the people don't worry guys this is the
beginning welcome we're gonna do a flash
live stream spoiler talk today it's
gonna be a blasty blast
um this movie is killing it at the box
office uh I've never seen a movie make
so much more money in my entire life
it's doing insanely well but uh before
we go into everything
um I got a couple of announcements that
I want to make especially for those who
are going to be watching some of the
playback but if you're live you're going
to be the first ones to hear this right
now it's we're going to be the this is
the official announcement for it
um you know what I'm gonna just
temporarily just make it about us really
quick well hold on oh wait hold on a sec
we are going to be having a panel at
Comic-Con yes yep uh it's Saturday yep
don't worry John you're invited uh thank
you John's just now finding out I
already just I know I already booked the
I already booked her hotel John so we
are going to be having what Saturday is
it gonna be on a Saturday panel the 20th
like Saturday that's the day whatever
the Saturday is or the Marvel of panel
is uh yeah so apparently our WonderCon
panel went over so well because we had
that like on a Sunday morning uh which
is like a shitty time to have a panel
like just an awful time and then we
ended up like having so many people show
up that they offered they were like do
you we can give you Comic-Con and we'll
give you Saturday a few hours before
Marvel and that's just flabbergasted wow
that's a really generous offer and
admittedly was a little bit stressed
because Comic-Con is already a very
stressful event
um but then enough people talking to
were like you should just do it and I
was like fine okay we'll pull the plug
and uh yeah we're gonna be
John's reaction live and it's very funny
yeah
I can imagine many logical scenarios in
which that would be like oh you can only
do the two of you yeah I mean I'm sorry
but I've known it for like a weekend
yeah that's very very exciting I I
cannot even believe it I'm honored I'm
not worthy uh so yeah a large part
thanks to koi large part thanks to Paul
uh can we say isn't it yeah my publicist
all right cool yeah we're gonna stop by
IMDb we can mention Paul so yeah guys um
oh you know what I just noticed this
chat is not refreshing that's a problem
oh my God I was like I was like no one's
interacting in the chat
no one likes it like this whole time I
was like I don't think anyone in this
life so if you saw our energy I was like
Greg was right we shouldn't have a panel
if you saw our energy I was like I don't
remember
the most excited right now because I'm
like no one's interacting with us
like this battle is not gonna go outside
the enthusiasm rides off and then I
realized the chat was just frozen head
so that was so funny I literally lived
what you thought wow this is really not
going over again gotta call Paula just
tell him no man we don't want that heat
that's why my reaction was because like
no one else was telling me how to react
yeah what is uh I think cineo starts the
19th so I think it'd be the 22nd is it
uh San Diego no no we're yeah we're the
22nd we're 20 seconds Wednesday's
preview night so yeah the 22nd all right
well here we go guys let's talk about
taking a lot of energy let's get it
going um so real now before we go into
the spoilers yes we're obviously going
to have a lot of spoilers here
um we're gonna be doing this spoiler
talk I keep saying spoilers we have not
heard John's opinion on the movie so
John why don't you go ahead kick us off
uh because uh coin and I we re-watched
it uh it went to the premieres is plus
one yeah and
um I'll tell you guys uh it it didn't
actually get better for me which I was
surprised by I was convinced it would
get better for me on the second viewing
and it actually and it's really
especially with comic book movies
usually they go up and this one it kind
of went down a little bit for me I'm
still like a 7.5 I would say like a
seven to seven point five uh out of ten
it got better for me after the second
viewing not during it but only by like a
little bit
but John what you saw one time what was
your did you say this like oh you see it
twice I saw it I I heard uh off camera
what your first opinion was
um did it go up for you the second time
around because you were on the lower
side like he was way lower than us whoa
I came out yeah I came out of the first
viewing uh very conflict like that night
I was like wow I have no idea how to
feel because at first I was like okay
and then you know after an hour I was
like oh if I like that at all and then
an hour later I was like but there's
some really great stuff in there and
then I saw it the second time and the
second time was a much more smooth
viewing experience and it was a much
more fun viewing experience partially
because the second time I went in
knowing to expect a comedy I I looked at
it like a comedy the second time and
that alleviated a lot of things but I
still left with many of the same
takeaways if that makes sense it was a
smoother more enjoyable film experience
the second time I was less distracted by
like whoa where's the tone uh but yeah
it's still a kind of strange hodgepodge
with some things in it that I really
really like some things in it that are
quite questionable and a lot that's
pretty good yeah you know okay so there
you go yeah it's a little all over the
place this movie it went up from a 7.7
to us either 7.9 or an 8.1 for me I know
it's on an 8.0 so it's either 7.9 or 8.1
uh and then I think that's because of
the the time I've thought about it and
the times I've talked on other shows the
times that I've like conferred with
people that had highs and lows with it I
do think that the heart of it is so much
better than it should have been with all
the interference and I think a lot of my
negatives are because of the
interference which doesn't change the
fact that that is part of the movie like
it is very much a five movie movie but I
do think that it accomplished so many
things that are nigh impossible like I
genuinely feel like I know who the flash
is now I genuinely feel like I know uh
like a good take on a Flashpoint story
which is very dense I do feel like it
was a great Batman 3 but it never wasn't
a Flash movie I do feel like they did
the fan service in a way that didn't
feel uh in the first two acts anyway
that didn't feel like it undercut the
film itself and the hardest thing of all
for me was it was a movie that was so
heart-wrenching but also genuinely funny
I laughed way more than I expected I
genuinely had some belly laughs and I
almost cried uh near the end so it did
enough for me that I was able to look
past some of my issues with the style of
the CGI and with uh the clear five
movies that it had to be fascinating
um yeah I it's cool okay
it's like a seven none of us have like
an uh it seem to have this like over
glowing praise I would say that if you
watched our uh uh like at least the
review that coin I did out of the
theater the things that I thought were
strengths still stand uh but on my
second viewing the things that I was
saying I had issues with actually became
even more underscored for me when I was
watching it and I just couldn't look
past a lot of things that it became and
the and the novelty of fun actually
diluted a tad bit for me
um
yeah yeah yeah I'm able to see past like
the excitement of seeing Michael Keaton
and um you know CGI Cameo Fest uh so
which I know which the CGI the cameos at
the end never really did anything for me
because the actors aren't there I mean I
know you can't get you know Christopher
Reeves there Nick Cage filmed his and I
did not get that impression it looked
like someone could have made that on
YouTube I think the Lego animation that
that kid did for across the stars
but like if he filmed that I wish that
they actually let him have a line that
way it would have felt like at least we
got somewhat of a character even gave
George Clooney a lot yeah and I I liked
the Clooney a lot I really thought that
after years of Clooney apologizing
having his one line be like [__] Batman
was genius like I thought it worked well
guys in the chat can you spam for me
really quick
um spam for me out of ten uh what what
would you rate your experience of The
Flash well I want to see what you all
have to say I also did my DC ranking
that was very interesting to look at
where I put it because I was like what
do I feel about that like it's hard to
put it with other movies because it's so
like what is this one and it is very
much a victim of its own hype I think
man it did not help having time
well you see I I think where the movie
is I I re this is when I really I
imagine we briefly said it in our
non-spot okay so where are we at oh yeah
we're on the same page yeah see when we
when I first saw it I was an eight uh
and then the second time it went down
like 7.5 to 7 so I'm like somewhere in
that range
I think that the threat of General Zod
is just not a there's no palpable
tension at all to that uh I like what I
really feel like they needed to do was
take a little bit of a note out of how
they handled Avengers end game because
you know Thanos dies in that movie and
then they have a Thanos coming back from
the past too so it's like a Zod
situation right
and that and game did such a good job at
re-establishing the threat of Thanos all
over again
to the point where you get to that final
battle it's still intense you still
understand the Threat Level and whatnot
whereas Zod it really relies on you just
having seen Man of Steel like
it's not just like you'd be like man I
love Sonic Man of Steel and I did it I
wasn't so I was not only I just wasn't a
fan of the way it's always portrayed but
I also thought they really failed at
re-establishing Zod so much in this
movie to the point that when they got to
there I didn't even see how he was much
of a threat until he like actually
killed Supergirl and then I was like and
then I was like okay maybe he's better
this time around or something like that
and and there's little things about the
pacing that we're really just bugging me
throughout and when it first became
highlighted to me it was when
Batman and the two flashes they
parachute off of the plane and then it
just cuts to they're on the ground
instead of like seeing them parachute I
was like okay all right we're skipping a
beat and then that kind of just keeps
happening a lot where every scene after
they save Supergirl
just starts becoming like this is good
enough like move on this is good enough
I feel like this they don't even get it
they didn't even get a moment with like
Supergirl suit you know it's just like
cut to her we're in the suit and even
she's like I don't care about Humanity
five minutes later I'm here to help
Humanity you know it just starts moving
so fast uh and then even when they get
to the Multiverse collision at the end
I'm like there was nothing really set up
about this
is to be a a a finale threat you know
and I look guys the reason I'm talking
so much is because my issues with the
movie couldn't say in a non-spoiler
because this is obviously spoilers yeah
and I want to have a more balanced
opinion even as I'm talking about it
right now it's just I got some things
that I'm like I want to clarify what I
want to talk about it I had that hard of
a time doing a non-spoiler ever yeah
almost every scene didn't finish
they were so like
quick quick get it over with it it
started becoming that way especially
after they save Supergirl and there's a
four hour cut sorry John oh no no you're
good it's a movie to me that feels like
the the parts are greater than the sum
of the parts is greater than the whole
it's like there are a lot of great
scenes beats moments but like the whole
that they turn into doesn't feel as
well-rounded as certain moments do you
know and I think like on the second
viewing I was like okay like for a movie
that has to chop chop through the second
half like it could be worse it could be
choppier but it is very apparent or it
feels like a lot of stuff was changed
remixed Etc and there are so many scenes
where you could tell like by the way
people are facing like oh there was more
dialogue or something here that got
excised
yeah it was kind of like that uh
throughout you know what I gotta go I've
got a big question big question yes
how come Barry never bothered to find
out who killed his mom
because that's the sequel he just didn't
have time to run over after dropping off
some fixing the tomatoes on the Shelf I
don't feel like who's the one who killed
my mom how come Barry never could find
out real real answer sequel my answer in
headcanon was I think he thought then he
would try to change it
wouldn't you then want to act on it I
feel like with the amount of power he
has in the movie I'm like he would at
least want to be like okay let me try to
convict this guy in my present time then
yeah but that's a huge change everything
his mom dies
after his mom was leaving he didn't find
her who actually killed his mom Michael
C Hall is yellow flash
so it yeah it would be I mean yeah okay
the answer is reversible but but the
movie plays it like it was someone who
just broken and stabbed it which is what
you think yeah that's the rationale but
it was reverse flash which I think was
supposed to be the sequel which
according to the box office will not
occur but I hope that Sasha Kaye gets to
play Supergirl again I I I didn't I left
I think the reason it's grown on me is
that you're right the pieces are what I
think of and Annie Mushi has said
there's a four hour cut I think that
might be the movie that like I would
love to experience but when I think of
the pieces I'm so impressed by the
pieces I think it went up from that like
C plus to B minus ish but that's also so
tricky and just the the scope of DC
there's like an anti-belt curve of DC
for me because like DC is is a different
animal of how their movies go really
really low to really really high they
don't have an average like if you look
at DC and whether you agree with which
ones you think are A's and which ones
you thinks are F's you inherently think
some are like tens and summer twos
because there are Snyder fans and
they're DC fans and there are some that
are both but rarely do they agree which
one is their best that's why I like
ranking these movies because it's so
vitrollic but there is nowhere to put
flash which is that's the fascinating
thing to me is it's like I had more of a
good time watching this than most DC
films I was more joyous so that
inherently is going to be high but it is
a movie that doesn't have scenes that
end because there's a four hour movie
out there well we okay all right so
sweet I want to make sure because I feel
like this is my fault I totally kicked
this off with negatives
so much right I don't want to yeah there
is a lot that I I think does click and
so yeah but John I mean uh again I mean
what what other guys I'm saying that we
got so many uh super chats that I do
want to get to those uh thank you I
really do appreciate it a lot obviously
they like live stream playbacks don't
ever really have like good cpms so to
you know the super chats really do help
out with the channel per minute
um per meal it's just yeah it's what the
ad revenue is okay on a playback so yeah
no they really do help out a lot so
thank you guys and also created some fun
audios for the ones who are ten dollar
super chats 15 10 enough 15 and up and
25 and up great so we got some fun
audios for you guys yes yes you're gonna
like it John name some positives to flow
us and then we're gonna get to some
super chats yeah because we've got to
talk about some things in here dark
flash at the end we gotta talk about
that Batman George Clooney Cameo oh [__]
he's doing Batman talking about more of
the cameos and uh but yeah Johnny what
uh what other pause what are some
positives that you felt yeah absolutely
uh I mean I think the best thing in the
movie certainly is just the emotional
core with Barry and and for me uh with
Andy muschietti one thing I've been
waiting for and hoping for is to see
more of just his voice and personality
in some of these movies and I thought
that the stuff with Barry and Nora
especially and I could be projecting but
it feels like that was kind of informed
by and ripped from his own life and I
thought that stuff was really sweet and
I loved this sort of aspect of culture
they added on top of that I thought
while the two berries there are times
when the effects are very noticeable but
the 80 percent of the time-ish for me uh
you know that it was working it was
really working and very impressive and
they acting like it has to go on a
hero's journey into two different
directions which I think is genius
because Heroes stories are always that
like young Ian hero's journey and you've
got a young one going on the just don't
be annoying Arc and then you've got the
mature one going on like how do I become
a hero and accept the fact that I have
to let my mom die I have to effectively
kill my mother in order to save the
world so you've got just maturity and
then true maturity so it's like maturity
of Life maturity of hero and they both
cause each other it's this really
beautiful and those are the moments that
that I think it goes higher for me
because just thinking of the the
causality of that and the acting
required to do of and the directing you
have to direct a whole movie of the
young one direct a whole movie with the
mature one because like they they're not
you know the haircut and all the changes
and then also he has to act opposite not
him because he doesn't exist there's
only one Ezra and that's such powerful
acting to receive nothing from your
counterpart to to be able to act off
nothing and have that fully formed
versions of you so impressive for the
acting and then Sasha like there's so
much love for her in here and that makes
me happy because if you think about it
she's the only character that's new we
have so much love for for Aflac and
Keaton and as has played this character
before and then she's taking on a role
that people are like everyone is wanting
Cavill and she's able to come in and be
this positive like
Sasha yeah because they don't give her a
lot to do whatever she's there it's like
Sasha actually I feel like does this
stupendous job considering the fact that
she is not given a lot to do and I know
that's that's a default for a lot of
people
but it's also really impressive what
she's been able to pull off uh with that
one with the limited screen time that
she has like 12 minutes to 15 minutes
like she's not in it that much because
yeah you could feel that Brewing that
Brewing rage underneath her but you also
don't feel like she's villainy I do have
a question though a big question for the
check can you guys help me out here one
they left the suit with her in her
little prison whatever I'll accept that
two was she captured
immediately upon arriving on Earth and
she's been there the entire time because
I understand I get it what they're going
for it's a riff on when Superman is
captured in the flashpoint comic but one
thing I loved about that super Superman
uh portrayal is that he really feels
like an alien entity that does not know
humanity and so you're kind of like oh
[__] should we have awoke in this guy
a creature raised in captivity right but
in here I'm like is this is something
pretty acquainted with like they speak
the language and I feel like she was
protecting
um Cal that was coming and then once he
got there she never was able to do it so
she wasn't hiding that was the vibe I
got and then eventually got then she got
captured
I don't know what to attribute anything
to in terms of the writer or the
director or or just Studio whatever but
uh but yeah when it comes to to that
part of the story
um
God I just completely lost my truth what
was the last thing you said uh the Sasha
kidnapped yeah like with with her I I I
had to wonder if it was related to I
really like the Michael Keaton
explanation of time oh timelines and the
spaghetti thing and that made me wonder
because Kalel you know as we know him by
this time with Zod is like an adult man
and she seems like a teenager so I was
also like when did you get here in
relation when they sent Kalel because if
you guys were here at the same time you
would either be older or they sent him
later and so I couldn't tell if she was
supposed to be older than the child or
if she was gonna like grow up parallel
and watch out for him so I kind of got
confused as to like the whole context of
how her character existed and then on
top of that was like okay and then how
does her like understanding of our
speech work and all that stuff I
definitely gathered that she was older
and has been here a while because when
he said like you know the child did not
survive the procedure she she had seemed
to be looking for him at least some so
that implies she's been here and also
been in prison because you can't look
for him in prison so like though that's
her being here a bit and I assume she
was at least like 15 years old okay
that's fair enough and yeah people are
saying she's behind my logic she was
older when she arrived hey Bucky Barn
thanks for being here and also guys if
you can leave a like on the stream that
would be great uh yeah but overall I
mean I'd always kicked off with some
negatives making it sound like we really
don't like the movie uh overall I I
think the movie though is saved a lot by
by Fun and and intention you know like
there's I think at the end of the day
there is a
a fervent approach to the way mushieri
went about it regardless if there's some
editing choices that I'm like it's
really obvious you had to bear [__] down
you know I still think the passion is on
display yeah I still think there's a lot
of love and care put into it
um despite whatever some people feel
about the CGI which of course does
bother me from time to time
weirdly this is a strange movie for me
with the CGI because I am one of those
people who I'm like oh no that's bad
that bothered by it
only with the Ezra faces when it
bothered me when I could really see it
was like an emotional but most of the
time well because I could but okay like
when it didn't work for me camp with the
cameos it did nothing for me emotionally
because they're not characters and I was
just like yeah they they animated them
in here that's that's cool
um but they don't it's like looking at
Space Jam new Legacy people like they
put on costumes but they're not a
character they're not actually there you
know so that did nothing to make it
tangible for me
um so those did nothing for me but
really the speed force that a lot of
people which looks like you know yeah
they do look like PS3 faces yeah the
chronosphere at the
same time it didn't bother me because
that actually felt intentional to me the
way they look in the speed not when
you're showing Nick Cage who's supposed
to be exactly from a Multiverse and he's
peeking in and watching the actions
happen sure I'm talking about like the
different variations and different times
that could be happening and stuff like
that actually didn't bother me because
something felt purposeful about that
effect one thing would have when you get
a brief chance to examine it too there's
like a cool flip book layering that they
do yes and they Cascade down and up I I
would have one thing would have made a
lot of it better for me just one thing
is if after the baby shower scene the
baby that came out of the microwave was
a real baby then it would have implied
to me that in the speed force the
perception Barry has of these things is
that that weird CGI versus the baby
stayed like Ellie McBeal baby when they
were not speedy and I was like oh that's
just bad CGI baby but if the the baby
shower was like because he's so fast
they look different that would have been
a reasoning so then when it wasn't I was
like oh that's just bad baby yeah I mean
they I guess you don't want to put a
real baby of any kind in any microwave
reel or it's a fake because they cut to
him holding a real baby but when he
pulls it out you're like that you put
that baby in a microwave yeah I'm still
conflicted about the CG faces but uh
yeah
and and the first time I saw it I was
filled with a sense of cool because I
like the flash show I mean I liked what
I saw originally I saw the first four
seasons and I gave up substantial um but
there were sequences even in the flash
show I was like that's really cool
they're doing this on TV I wonder what
they could do with the movie and a lot
of times like when he first like that
first speed force run is immaculate to
me sure uh like even though it's sure
looks cartoony I still think it's
awesome as hell and I love that they can
really capture the distance of him going
from oh my God Central Central City yeah
star cities
uh Central City to Gotham and how they
really capture that distance uh and the
baby shower moment was great but well
and it's a scene when I realized too is
is that prologue is really cool because
it's a scene within a scene within a
scene and then it all wraps back around
to the sandwich guy and like there's a
lot of really fun and clever like
dilated scenes like that scene within a
scene within a scene yeah the reception
and that's neat which is fun and it's in
the spirit of The Flash and here she
finally got to play she got to show up
and provide Exposition I was happy for
Kirsty to get to be Iris West all right
guys
um we got some super chess I definitely
want to catch up on or they're coming in
right now uh thank you guys uh so what I
wanted to ask you guys in the chat the
big hype going into this movie was
Michael Keaton more than anything else
Michael Keaton so can you guys spam in
the chat for mwah
nine uh nine out of ten nine out of ten
oh no
that's nine out of ten what would you
say you thought of Michael Keaton's
return
Batman
see what I did there
so see what I did koi did he rise in
return dang thing man
he'll play him forever I liked Michael
Keaton I thought he did a fine job the
second time it played a lot smoother to
me meeting him because the first time
with him you know I get you got the
mystery of the build up of like oh who's
under that all that hair uh
the second time very young the second
time I was able to drink in his perfor
because he's doing a sort of a more
subtle performance and I appreciate
because you know very people loved him
oh man I do think there are aspects of
like you could remove him and not all
the things would change necessarily but
I did like him and I thought he did a
really nice job like he showed up
certainly for this movie the writing of
the time Paradox was genius I think
that's like maybe the most succinct
explanation I've ever seen a Multiverse
be explained and I have craved spaghetti
since I've actually Bots play and have
not yet cooked it but I love the Retro
causal thing the genius yeah Not only
was the mom dying about tomato sauce and
spaghetti was the family meal but then
spaghetti is the time travel there's so
much great spaghetti not since 8 Mile
and I've thought of spaghetti this one I
do love his Batman fight as much as
you're like that's definitely not
Michael Keaton yeah because you see like
what they go with the
um the the other Batman that we've
gotten since like Christian Bale
you can and you can fathom that might be
Christian Bale underneath the suit you
can fem that's Ben Affleck you can
fathom that's Robert Pattinson well
Michael Keaton's kicking ass for like
he's fighting the Giant when he's like
hopping around but then he gets the
ground he's really tired but it's still
a really cool oh it's a great secret
it's a great it's like the actual
martial arts of it all was awesome and I
felt like it continued for me tonight
because he didn't have Kryptonite he
didn't have any way to fight these
things so it was like What if that
Batman stopped fighting soon after we
left him and then had to do this out of
nowhere like the old Tech worked I would
have loved to see Marlon Wayans at the
same time that would have been can you
imagine
you guys don't know he was originally
Robin still gets residuals oh my God
does he Marlon Wayans gets money for
Batman good as he deserved it got cast
he's been my favorite Wayans brother for
a long time I'm at Billy D Williams at a
uh a con and I didn't have him sign a uh
anything Lando because he's my like two
face so he signed a two-face comic for
me and it's one of my surprise
possessions absolutely it is we're so
close well uh yeah guys alrighty so
let's kick this off all right we got
Dakota Jones with a 10. let's hope this
doesn't blow out anyone's eardrums you
let me know
run Barry run to the super chats
hey we'll never know we can't hear it
but you can it's so weird on our end we
can't hear it did you hear it and was it
oh I can verify they all were right
before we went live
let us know if it's too loud made me
chuckle every time
you can read his thing while I do
okay
Dakota yeah thanks John
yeah
he said I love this movie seeing Ben
again was a highlight and loved his
opening scene wish we had more time with
dark Flash and Supergirl was that Ezra
it looked like Matthew Modena me in some
shots yeah I I liked I liked Ben
Affleck's action scene there are Parts
about when he's getting tossed around on
the freeway that don't
it didn't bother me as much the second
time but at first time I'm like there's
like no weight to the way he moves
around here and he's like the second he
gets off the bike there's like no way to
the way he moves yeah
um
Ben Affleck really raved about that
Wonder Woman moment before like he said
if I'm not mistaken he said that was the
moment he figured out that was the
moment he figured how to play Batman and
and maybe it's the way it's cut together
but I'm like I don't know this feels
like real Justice League [__] to me it
feels like there when she leaves there
was like a conversation between him and
Barry that got like snipped out and then
Barry's just like I gotta go get my
sandwich box Superman was in that scene
I think the opening was like a Justice
League not just two of them I think it
was everyone and then they had to cut
around it and probably I don't like the
bat suit honestly when he's standing in
the on the I'm not a fan of the way the
bat suit looks uh I wish they just kind
of kept what they did with Zack Snyder's
Justice League or bvs there's something
that was like I mean you needed a kind
of armored suit to explain how he's
surviving that tumbling on the freeway
like I understand that but it wasn't a
huge fan of look I did like his Ben
Affleck you know just him being Bruce
Wayne he loved his Bruce in this and
felt like that was probably a longer
scene
um but it does set up uh the idea of you
know like
these experiences is what made you and
you can really see that the second you
interact with young Barry who did not
experience the trauma you know I also
love that how that paralleled with what
the difference in the bruises would be
because with with young Bruce Ben
Affleck's older young Bruce we see him
kind of addressing how he would interact
with trying to save and how like he's
just lonely and he's sad and he's broken
and then we see a fully sad lonely Bruce
but he actively wants to help as soon as
he's like wait you did the thing I
couldn't do and I love that Ben
Affleck's Bruce is just like kind of
more broken because he doesn't ever even
get hope he doesn't even get that s like
he just stays like removed whereas
Keaton's like you know you brought me
back this is the the bringing uh full
circle what you were able to do is the
thing I couldn't accomplish whereas Ben
Affleck is a totally different take on
that character that I I felt but I did
think that like the humor was cut by the
edit and I do feel like Ben Affleck and
muschetti shot way more than is the
stuff Ben Affleck finally definitely
what do you think of Ben Affleck I liked
Ben Affleck uh I I liked his later scene
with Barry most of his appearance that
was the scene where I was like okay I
could tell he sort of figured that I
thought of that thing he said and I
didn't realize it was from the Wonder
Woman scene but yeah I I liked the
opening with him a lot better the second
time the first time it was sort of like
okay like this feels very sort of
impersonal in a way or something there's
something about the business's usual
quality that he was doing it with the
clicked way better for me the second
time because this movie does in some
ways remind me of watching a DC animated
movie
that's exactly what we said yeah yeah
and and Batman in some of those moments
can be sort of like business as usual
like just let me handle this Barry you
know uh but yeah I I liked that opening
scene a lot more the second time around
and it kind of it captured that fun of
like oh yeah the Justice League is
around doing Justice League stuff yeah
and uh and yeah and then and also too
you you commented about uh you know
flash which was something that I you
know it's like predictable as it is I
thought they could have made something
like really fun and interesting out of
that and something kind of Rich out of
that and it was a bummer not to be able
to because too they just give them so
many like mannerisms and he's like
drooling everywhere and he's yeah
there's just something interesting about
that and and you're thinking about
Matthew Modine what what struck me about
Ezra Miller in this is is there's so
many times where the effect you can kind
of tell but what I realized is there are
shots where they're not both in the same
scene it's just like a close-up on one
Berry and they'll have a totally CG face
okay and that's the part that I was like
what is hap why why do we have like a
Batman's mustache thing or Superman's
mustache thing going on with Barry's
face when there's nobody else in the
shot even it's like in the plane and
stuff like that
well thank you Dakota Ismail Montoya
oh someone's like you're too picky we
either love everything we're too picky
it's always the case right chills haters
we're both I wish we got one just one
more Ben Affleck scene but it's still
it's always nice to just see him and I
did like it all his bike sequences a lot
we also saw him get to be Bruce Wayne
getting out of an SUV at the premiere
and I was like that's Bruce Wayne yeah
is male Montoya
hey guys not my favorite Multiverse
movie but okay I still understand how
they jump to a different Earth without
choosing its number
it's a good question I'm sure koi has a
justification so in the comic books
there's this actually really fun concept
of Earth one or two all these things and
we have that idea for years since the
first crisis the crisis in DC is kind of
like a reboot of the whole system so
Infinite Crisis Christ independent Earth
there's all these things and one of them
the most iconic ones Supergirl dies and
they try to reset all continuities and
they end up like renumbering the comics
and our in our continuity like in in our
world as a way to mirror that but what's
fun is every Earth thinks it's Earth one
so there's this really good like running
joke of like yeah how would you number
them it's not like we all call each
other so everyone thinks they're one but
everyone else labels them other ones so
there is no numbering system except for
the one that that own Universe labels
because there's no communication between
them so there's like maps and stuff
where Batman has like these things but
you don't like pick it in this case
Barry was thrown out of it and landed in
a different coronal timeline because of
his own choices but like that Earth
wouldn't be labeled anything except
Earth one to them just as our Earth
wouldn't be anything but Earth one to us
yeah see it's explained in the movie had
an answer for it I said I wouldn't I did
right
Johnny ooh Johnny's saying
cameos are knowing an actor in the film
beforehand
I only knew about I'd only heard of like
one or two rumors but I didn't know half
the things that were gonna appear here
uh I heard about
I mean everything was kind of semi-ruin
for me uh it's just ruined for me well I
mean the Nick Cage one
I heard about that I heard a Superman
Cameo and then in my notification Bells
uh someone put Nicolas Cage I was
scrolling Instagram damn it I managed to
avoid that until someone said Nicholas
Cage I was watching one of those things
where he breaks down his career and
somebody asked him about Superman and he
was like you know he said something
about like I mean I would love to do I
mean like it could happen like not for
very long but you never know and and I
was like I bet he's in the flash I'm
like that's a spoiler I was like he
didn't say it at all but I was like you
left that one little piece of openness I
bet you have a cameo in this movie uh so
I I knew the George Clooney because of
other people in our space that like to
ruin things well the George Clooney one
uh I mean they were this I think it was
Grace Randolph who put out that she was
hearing about people and then you know
like they put out like several Batman
and I was like
well I don't think Christian Bale's
gonna do it not without Nolan I feel
like it would be George Clooney and and
people I don't know how many people
thought it would be George Clooney as
well but to me it just made the most
sense based off of everything Christian
Bale has said I was like the one who's
more likely to have fun with this is
going to be George Clooney and that's
the funniest one it's like the best use
of that comedic does raise some
questions I thought the uh
post-crediting kind of answered those
questions
how
because Saint is saying Coy reminds me
of Sean Chandler half the time do the
point
Sean Chandler which way does he oh he
does the crossover point I just met him
at Megacon that guy's delightful yeah I
like that guy
um to me Christian unpronounceable is
saying thank you so much yeah I think
Flashpoint Paradox is still the best one
and it's exactly so it's also exactly
like the comic
uh they use the storyboards it managed
to be a full full-length feature film
which is like it's amazing Christian
unpronounceable thank you so much
Christian
to me the want to get nuts line felt
very shoehorned in
it doesn't make any sense he says it as
Bruce Wayne to the Joker which makes
sense because he's dealing with that
moment and he's he's literally doing a
commentary on him being nuts why would
Batman it's not a catchphrase Batman has
why would like years later 40 years
later I remember that thing I said under
duress when Joker kidnapped imma use
that it doesn't make sense hated it I
mean it didn't love that line I don't
mind it it's pure Nostalgia it didn't
make sense why would he say it Who
quotes himself except for I'm Batman I
mean what was the point of him going
yeah I'm Batman that happened to me that
made less sense when I'm like we we
learned already that he's Batman because
the girl earlier because that's what
Batman says because young Barry doesn't
realize still
no and that when they're eating this he
says wait you're Batman I love that
scene but he's still like surprised
they're in the bat cave for a long time
the thing that got me about the wanna
get nuts the the thing it wasn't
actually the line itself it's his
following line where he's like over
there at the controls and he's like you
know for the record I I can't remember
what the line is but he's like for the
record I think this is insane and I'm
like you were just down a minute ago you
literally were like let's get nuts yeah
which is it Keaton yeah I thought you're
not doing this against your will I
thought in the trailers that's when the
line was going to be used
to be when it's too well knows to get
him hit with some lightning I thought it
was trailer moment I didn't think it
would be in the movie you know it was
fun I was looking at our trailer
reaction and we were we caught the
footage where Supergirl was carrying
flash to the sky yeah and uh you were
you were said like I wonder if he's
taking her up there to taking him up
there to get shot because he needs more
lightning yeah and I was I don't know I
was like laughing about that
it happened
oh exactly what happened
nobody does have to shock him to get his
powers back and Supergirl has to take
him up there yeah and it was I mean I
loved that moment because it was so
emotionally cathartic but if we'd had
one more Sasha kayaking scene it would
have been like there's just so much that
could be I want a three hour cut between
the two and the four mushy Eddie cut oh
she had he cut Cameron Dane Scott he's
got two five dollars so
run ferry run to the super trucks
Cameron Dane Scott uh thank you for the
endless hours of content I'm going
through a little Canon event right now
my dog passed away last week that
[__] sucks sorry dude I'm sorry John
has lost a couple of dogs uh we lost our
family dog a few months ago that was
hard sorry that was extremely hard yeah
I was there in the room and it happened
oh and have you lost something I have my
childhood dog passed when my third year
in La so I was like freshly away from
home so it's really hard to like not be
there and I'd gone to visit her like six
months before so that was kind of nice
but I like that dog slept in my bed with
me throughout like from five to twenty
that's hard man uh I broke it with my
fiance of six years
well I wish that happens before you get
married yeah sure it's not easy better
it happens before marriage at every
stance wish we could give you a big old
bear hug all the three of us continues
to say not every problem has a solution
you have no idea how great it's been to
sit back and listen to you guys during
these dark times thanks much love well
thank you Cameron Dane Scott
um for being here and I hope things get
better for you it's not easy but you can
survive through turbulent times makes
you a stronger person I love I love that
people have that uh kind of like catch
phrase terminology for them to get
through these dark moments I think I
think the beauty of this movie is that
not everything has a solution I think
one of the big like there's thousands of
beautiful things about spider-verse but
I do love the message of like trauma
does change you and it can be for the
better I feel like Barry doesn't fully
learned that lesson
really because he moves the camera I'm
like dude he moves like hands he moves
the cans to get him to look up and he's
still messing with time which is why
there's literally vacation
but he's only affecting his presence but
he's still caught but with the whole
retro causal thing if you change he
still goes to a different timeline
because George that proves yeah so let's
talk about this George thing
George proves that yeah George proves he
said I thought George Clooney was the
same version same person as okay
let me try to understand this I don't
think this Michael Keaton is the
continuation of the Tim Burton one I
feel like this is an ALT Universe of
that happens to have the the uh imagery
of the Tim Burton one yeah variants I
don't feel yeah that's what I think is
happening
so are they implying that like Batman
Forever and Batman and Robin are not the
continuations of the Michael Keaton
films because I thought that's what we
were doing with George Clooney
with you know in Batman and Robin so do
you hear what I'm getting I have always
thought that with this explanation of
time the actor that plays Alfred Michael
go being all four of the movie's first
alfreds imply that Alfred is one of
those crossover points in the spaghetti
that they are different universes so
Batman one and two is one Universe
Kilmer's another duplicate on the Alfred
yeah and then in in the killer when they
do reference an event that had happened
before in in Michael in in Michael
Keaton's but I think that was one of
those incidents that happens in every
Universe I think there's two movies one
in one movie and then this is another is
my take yeah okay fair enough
Batman should shave it's really easy to
identify what Batman is when he's got a
big white man that's true
but can you imagine that goatee sticking
out of the cowl beautiful what I wish we
had
Burton verse Snyder's a lot of them but
I honestly feel like George Clooney
would be a fine Batman if they do like a
second shot I'm down yeah cause now now
is the time but I would be so down for
it I would like an Adam Westy one like a
nice fun like I would even be down for
him to return in a From Dusk Till Dawn
one of those like old man uh Seth geckos
kind of sequels I think that'd be cool
Batman Beyond George Clooney
I'd love that Charming voice one I bet
he could have his Ben Affleck moment of
like this is what toddler really had to
play Bruce Wayne I love that Saint Saint
is saying I think I like Zod more Man of
Steel oh absolutely he doesn't feel the
same here in fact I had to question a
tiny bit
where he was having certain moments that
came in so late into the film and I was
like wait I thought Michael Shannon
returned because are they just
repurposing him because he looks fake
[Laughter]
freaking mask man it makes him look all
plastic it was when he was having his
interaction with Cara I was like oh yeah
now that this is a Man of Steel yeah
okay so it's definitely all new
words
it's so funny that you're like oh no
this is really him he should well I
definitely felt like he wanted more out
of the role because he's talked very
openly about not being happy with like
what he got but I also think that like
when you put this many things in a movie
and it's not for hours why didn't he
follow Supergirl see stuff like that
didn't hit my Noggin until the second
viewing were these like little things
after a while like little thing on the
here's what happened first viewing
little things move past I'm having fun
second viewing these little things are
really stacking up and this is the point
where I'm like now I'm just seeing a big
list
so that's kind of what happened for me
you know
um
but every line of us said like I just I
have fun and like watching it also the
way the visuals translate on an IMAX
format is gorgeous it's really gorgeous
it's kind of crazy how some movies now
like have this necessitation to see on
IMAX and I'm like I think there's a
there's got to be a little bit of a line
with Cinema now where not every movie
like we saw spider verse on a regular
screen yeah and it was it's still
gorgeous yeah that movie is too pretty
it's better on IMAX but it didn't need
IMAX right there's a lot of movies now
where you're like I should probably like
you know you have to see this
yeah so the effects hold up on IMAX oh
for sure yeah because I've seen because
like because I've seen movies where IMAX
actually kind of hurts though when the
CGI is like stretched quantumania was
way better on a less good screen and I
saw it last night this movie on a less
good screen and had like a slightly
better time with that stuff so that's
funny
we got ourselves
wait everyone wait for it wait for it I
love his name oh
oh once we get to a 15 you'll hear the
other one I love the name I don't
remember what my audio was that I
created for this
oh it's huge
we can hear the big one did you guys
hear it I hope we all did that was great
yes
great sound bite yes excellent work I
liked it
we have no response 30 seconds it's
gonna catch up if you weren't able to
hear it it played all righty verified
damn it people okay there's some laughs
um the antagonist of the film uh is time
and consequences yeah yeah
yeah I think thematically uh that works
uh at the same time I think it kind of
loses a tad bit of its emotional heft
and focus on that it gets a little
muddied in there because they're like
rescue you know we gotta find Batman we
gotta rescue Supergirl then we gotta
find Zod so that is the real antagonist
that's why I think the speed force
finale
despite the fact that I didn't really
feel like this Multiverse Collision was
something they were really setting up
but I feel like we've seen so many
Multiverse things that you're like uh
you know
that's what happens
I still really felt the drama of that
and the gravitas of that especially when
you see that young Barry who is more ego
what I thought they did really well with
and I feel like this is where I kind of
debate with some people is youngberry
you know we he just becomes like so uh
Stern fast in the way like we got to do
this we got power like because Flash did
not our flash did not have a mentor he
did not have a guide to this and this
youngberry who's already just so much
more privileged and spoiled and arrogant
and obnoxious and is getting these
powers and is getting a quick handle on
them especially because he has the fact
that he gets mentored that he just gets
the best of it he's like I just gotta no
no no I can't deal with this I don't
know how to process that I gotta go we
gotta go we got to fix this we gotta fix
it so I actually really like that whole
speed force scene where he is just going
back in time constantly and and he he's
not learning his lesson one more time so
much to the point that he has to see
what he becomes in order to stop it yeah
yeah I really appreciate that it's a man
versus self story at its core and
consequences are like you said the true
Crux of what our reality is our reality
like our reality yeah and I really
appreciate that we have young Barry who
like you said is more entitled who is a
little bit more like I can do whatever I
want I don't have this loss and we have
our berry the regular one that lost
everything having to mature but what I
really love about that third Berry is
not only did he feel like he could do
anything because he didn't have that
that realization but the person that he
started as matured because of our berry
so therefore when he gets killed by
himself that maturation happened and
wouldn't have occurred causing that
Paradox that negates everything and I
think that's a really beautiful message
of almost your Uncle Ben scenario so he
had to have a mentor in some way whether
that's loss whether that's a Canon event
whether that's a mentor but he had to
have that thing in order to become the
hero that he was meant to become and
that negates him becoming a villain I
think that's a really beautiful message
of these are three ways your life can go
and one thing can change everything
exactly and that story is genius it just
had a lot of stuff around it yeah so as
we continue to read this off uh John you
want to read off the rest of that yeah
Zod dark Flash the Russians they're
there for action and tension but this
movie doesn't work that way while I was
watched it it was a bit more personal
surprisingly with all the added cast
members yeah I I I like there's so many
ways to look at this and I do think that
yeah you're right it's like it's not
necessarily about
these figures so much as it is about
what kind of emotional conflicts or how
they exacerbate this entire mess that
you know Barry has created here
um but yeah it's like it's it's a bunch
of big Stakes that are also like really
referential and I think that just pulls
your attention around sort of because
there are also just like a lot of really
great small moments within that time and
consequences theme and I love to like
you get even get that little flourish of
Eric Stoltz yeah
um and like I love that you have Barry
looking at himself and he like snaps at
himself and then also has that
realization of like I've talked to
people in life who have like met younger
people and then gone oh I can see myself
now and I can see what people have been
saying to me and and now this all hits
so much harder and I love that they
included that in this I also feel like
it's a commentary on how the fans
reacted to Ezra's
the first movie he's a lot and I feel
like the having him mature was a great
reaction to the audience wanting Barry
Allen to he this Barry is a step closer
to the Barry Allen of the comics he's
still not there but it's it's closer
yeah
the art the berry that we follow but
sure Barry is closer to Comic Berry than
original Berry and I like that that's
all on screen yeah I think when the
movie is
it was I'm a much bigger fan of
everything
outside of like even with the scene when
he's like discovering that there's no
meta-humans and stuff like I find that
really tense and while I like I think
Batman's a lot of fun in this movie and
Michael Keaton's Batman and I really
liked Sasha uh Sasha Kai's presence in
here and I even I liked the final fight
Battleship was so good a lot of [__]
like Stripes rocking tours
I thanked Jack so I think he gave them
stems to just completely remix the song
the final fight gets a lot of crap I've
noticed uh but I I think that you know
like Zod killing them off was great I
like Batman's action scenes does he get
like the mo I don't know if his death is
like super impactful but whatever I
still hit enough for me in that moment
is a Superman and I like the um I like
when him and bear the two berries are
working together I think that that's
really fun at that point I'm already
been seeing past so much whatever like
there's a lot of complaints about the
CGI and I get it like it's not it's not
the greatest
I for some reason I'm able to really
look past it and so and then that final
fight I was definitely able to really
look past it I like the final fight a
lot there's yeah time the first time
that was when my brain started to
liquefy and the second time I was like
this is actually really cool but my what
I'm trying to say is that my favorite
portions of this movie were everything
with the actual story of the the
emotional core of what berries going
through which which this movie is really
focused on in the first 20 to 30 like
before Batman pretty much like before
Batman you kind of lose sight of that
what's Batman's there and then when
everyone starts dying is when it really
starts bringing it back around to that
like you they talk a little bit here
like the whole thing with the monkey
they have that scene there with the two
berries with the monkey
um uh and then but but when it's really
focused on that is when this movie
really sings so it's like good emotional
court and then the other stuff is like
fun candy
what is that quick thing about the
ending uh I think that it did a really
beautiful third act DC ending like those
the DC movies have that type of ending
that is the big superhero ending but
three things I think it really enhanced
on that was one it was like an artist
Jam page which is like when different
artists like you know Greg pulo and Jim
Lee are painting the same page or
penciling and you see the different
styles it felt like Burton meets
mushyetti's flash meets Zack Snyder's
universe and I really love that the
three directing Styles yeah usually was
able to do like a jazz piece with the
third act and then it also uh all the
orange and blue that is Zack Snyder they
gave it a reason with Canon they gave
blue and orange the power sets for Flash
they were able to use those colors in a
way that actually made sense instead of
just visually aesthetically and I like
that in the Zack Snyder World Batman is
so paranoid of the kryptonians because
they feel like they're really Invaders I
love that Batman gets killed by a
Kryptonian I thought that was genius so
like those three things really sung from
it's a great point that highlights it
even more yeah I feel like nobody's
talking about that yeah so
um do you want to point this out in the
chat really really quick it's just like
30 seconds on it
um I I won Pierce so three do you notice
it on the second viewing the homeless
guy who when young Berry's first getting
his powers and he still was a pizza
yeah so he takes the pizza from the guy
and then because at the permission can
you talk to him at the premiere and like
we were like why is he here he was in
the thank yous and the credits
well yeah I mean he's he's in the movie
Mama yeah Andy muschetti director well
and Bill Skarsgard was there and so was
uh yeah like a bunch of the the I saw
Bill Skarsgard I was like oh [__] I
didn't recognize I was walking out of
the theater I had to thank Jessica
Chastain for her work on Molly's game
because it's so good and I was like oh
right they're friends but like it was
cool to see all the friends supporting
me she didn't forget the hell like how
many friends he made with that one movie
yeah
that's a really good movie too yeah
that's what I mean I think that like
actors know when they find a good
director and I love seeing that sport
yeah yeah and I mean whatever the the
response to this movie overall in the
financials and whatnot I'm excited for
more Andy mushieri joints still yeah
for brave in the Bold
I think he'll he won't have any issues
with the action I really feel like
he's had this interesting transition
where he went from you know like became
more popular Mama really popular with it
so we kind of knew him as the horror guy
yeah and he's on flash which has like
almost no horror
and then and then um
seeing him at like the premiere and
seeing how he interacts with people he's
a really silly guy he's a very very
goofy guy
um and those the way he just talks about
things in people like he he's very
playful with and and then some of the
earmarks and Sensibility choices of it
chapter two that kind of rub people
myself included the wrong way uh I'm
like ah this this feels like muschetti's
personality
started making more sense yeah yeah it
started making a lot more sense to me
even I was like watching him interact I
was like oh some of those it chapter two
choices suddenly like make a lot more
sense to me
um he's also truly one of us and I don't
feel like that it gets talked about
enough I feel like we talk about James
Gunn being a comic nerd we talk about
certain people loving these characters
Mushi and I talked about a bunch of
comics at the premiere after party we
literally broke down different arcs and
things I'm not going to tell you which
ones because I don't know what that
affects but it was really beautiful to
know that he loves certain arcs that I
love and I was able to give him a couple
recommendations so I'm really hoping
that like the way he is passionate about
all this now I think that's forever I
think that like him and James got are
working together for the passion of it
and I think that his cheekiness will
suit the Damian Wayne Bruce Wayne
because Damian Wayne like John and I
have fallen in love with with this this
take on Damian Wayne in the animated
movies because it allows Bruce to not be
so stoic it allows a little bit of that
that fun that much Yeti is so I think
him directing a family man Bruce and I
think him getting to be that playful guy
that he is like we literally sent Greg a
video like one in the morning because
Andy is a guy that like likes to
interact with fans to the scale of like
let's be joyous about loving Batman at
one in the morning that that's like so
unique in the film space you make a
movie and you're like okay we're done
he's like let's talk about it all night
and I love that man I feel like Raven
Bowl will be more focused it's gonna
it's just Batman and David so it's going
to be more focused and I feel like James
Gunn is really good at finding what a
person's strengths are and letting them
hone in on that he got to get his feet
wet with with the flash I I think that
he'll probably do a better job with
brave and bolt yeah
um so to me I'm excited for it because
no matter what family man Bruce I'm
actually really excited for him to take
on the brave in the Bold just because
it's really quick I know I describe this
as like being better looking at as a
comedy up top but I really do appreciate
like the the fun comic book you know
imaginative side of this Flash movie and
I do feel like with muschetti we can get
a Batman movie that is both comic book
kind of fun in an appropriate way but
that will also pull some of those horror
Aesthetics and some of those darker
Aesthetics like I think it'll be a
really nice kind of blend of what he's
clearly capable of in a big Blockbuster
super Aerospace but also with the you
know dark stuff could I disagree more
[Laughter]
alrighty let's see here Tucker wood is
sucker wood tuck it in let's
do this tuckerwood
to the super chats yeah we can hear it
yeah buddy we got there eventually I got
there
I wish there was a way I could like I'll
figure it out there Tucker wood if
there's a different Batman Clooney at
the end wouldn't that mean this is also
a separate universe and there should be
another Berry as well and if so where
was he why was he out of court it's
spaghetti that's how they've explained
it everything is spaghetti and always
came back but but someone's theorizing a
lot of theories are going that he
actually landed in a completely
different Universe this time with
Batman with with this George Clooney one
the more I think about how these this
orb representation of the universe is is
the more questions I have although I do
quite enjoy it but it does seem I guess
almost like every kind of likeness that
is one particular person is sort of
confined to a particular orb so I like
yeah I'm a little confused as to the
mechanics but it felt like he at least
created another alternate timeline yeah
that just has all the same events up
until right now and then koi explained
it pretty well earlier yeah
um also how does memory work in this
thing because I feel like you know you
would also remember if he was always
Clooney all of a sudden so you'd you'd
have your timelines memories because
when you change space time you're only
changing the space you're in not the
time you're in so your memories would
still be linear because you've lived
that time you've only changed space so
your memories would not suddenly like
incept yourself because otherwise that
would be changing both space and time
which isn't how they explain the chronal
yeah exactly yeah
um beautiful that's one of the answers
questions Greg
yeah yeah
no I'm just the earlier you were like
this is this this is this oh but those
times you were no at this time not
making fun of myself because I'm
thinking I'm just making things up I
just think those were not dots
all right let's go he's got two
run Barry run to the super chats
yeah man you've been practicing yeah
yeah I like it it's graceful so that's
how he dances too yeah thought the movie
was mostly good love the stuff to do
with Mary and his mom one of my biggest
scratches of CGI throughout the entire
film especially the VFX used to have two
berries and then we gotta find your
second one he said two really quick
we're not skipping any ones don't worry
um this is the second one yeah okay
um my other problem oh my God wait he
did if he did three whoa whoa we gotta
upgrade this is for the 15s and up we
want to get nuts
[Applause]
this is good
beautiful
instead of John Wesley ship or Grant
Gustin I I think Grant Gustin would have
hit harder than anything else we get a
generic Jay Garrick and multiple Batman
and Superman who are that's what I mean
they're just I agree with you I that
really doesn't do any the Nick Cage one
I think in honor of John especially
we're close to snap and all that yeah
there's a lot of reasons to love that
and then that never came to fruition so
to me I like that more than even the
Christopher Reeves one or the Adam West
appearance because that didn't actually
come to life so it's cool to see that
happen it is neat what I like about the
effect similar to like what happens with
George Clooney and even Supergirl uh who
played her in the Christopher Reeves
later yeah is like both rated both are
hated but there's something about seeing
them recognize where you're like yes we
can be chill about this now we have
other iterations that was cool to see
her get her flowers like yeah she got
introduced with the cast she came out
it's like a smaller talk about it's like
a smaller it's like a smaller way of how
like Andrew Garfield must have felt with
like oh people did like my spider thanks
guys yeah and um so yeah and then we've
gotta find uh hold on I've got a thing
on that as well
okay here he is yeah yeah okay oh let me
just pull it up here and then the
spider-verse movies had more love for
Spider-man than this movie had for the
flash as a character well it does seem
kind of like well the thing is the
spider Reverse movies have the ability
of so much Spider-Man to Riff on
everything we know about Spider-Man
we're here this is The Flash is just not
as well known this did feel like it had
love for the flag but I think for sure
it is spreading the love around for
other characters I do I I am curious as
to what people think because you have
like Christopher Reeve which people seem
pretty excited about but you has you
have Christopher Reeve which is one
thing but you also have George Reeves
who has like a difficult history with
the character dude yeah when I saw that
like I don't know if people realize but
George Reeve like might have killed
himself because of the character to see
him come back to play the character felt
like digging up a grave twice but uh I
thought the Nicholas Cage one was
um Shameless name drop uh Kevin Smith
was at the premiere and I had known
about that moment and writer when we
were talking to Kevin before the movie
he's like I would you think oh my God
because he knows how much I was excited
for this and uh he was like what do you
think I'll think and like the amount of
willpower it took not to tell that man
that his moment that has caused so many
ramifications like John Peters is now
known as the the Spider Guy and also
like they even put it in that PTA movie
where Bradley Cooper plays him and one
of Kevin Smith's quotes about John
Peters is something Bradley Cooper says
like so Kevin Smith has caused these
ripples throughout time and space so to
see that spider I feel like honestly
that was mushieri not only giving a a
great Easter egg in the movie but it
felt like an industry moment it felt
like the the Eric Stoltz joke was like
if you guys know time travel jokes and
it felt like the spider joke was like if
you're a deep cut nerd there were so
many moments that felt like layers of
Easter egg that I really liked the
conceptual delivery more than the actual
visual because I'm with Greg where if if
it looks like uh this this uncanny
valley I I don't connect to it
emotionally but I got to go like oh a
turducken of references that's
delightful so I agree with you with what
you're saying but I think me personally
I got more out of it because of my
connection to Kevin in the industry and
John obviously yeah why aren't the
Superman try to do anything why were
they just watching stuff happen
[Music]
yeah James Stevens hey James hey just
joined I know this isn't related to
flash enjoyed the film and daddy Clooney
Curtis if you guys are consider reacting
to succession
I think that's the show I'm just gonna
watch on my own time ever since I've
heard great things heard great things
I've heard it's amazing did it just end
it just said it's definitely not gonna
react to it yeah
um the Intrigue on that thank you so
much
just joking
boy freaking who who lost the Wolverine
oh uh Russell Crowe no no no
no no the guy who's in the race car
now
don't worry they'll bring him back for a
dead reckoning part two do you know
here's the Russell Crowe passed and
recommended you jack but it's my
favorite Hollywood thing it's like
literally top five like most ridiculous
Russell Crowe had just done Gladiator
when you think about the movie Gladiator
do you think wolves mean either
apparently his like uh spirit animal or
whatever the more appropriate title for
that thing is now in culture uh is a
wolf and they has like a scene with a
wolf and Russell Crow is just on
Gladiator which had a wolf in it so he
thought Wolverines were wolves and he's
like I don't want to be known as the
wolf guy I'm not gonna play Wolverine
similar reason why he passed on Aragorn
he did it was because he's just a
gladiator he didn't want to be
typecasting that he's always doing the
Pope's Exorcist I was gonna say that
Aisha Kevin Smith is the Nexus being of
our universe he really is he's Stanley
and um all rats and Stanley and Captain
Marvel means all the usq movies are
Canon and Marvel Joe Coughlin
um 85 of the movie I was at a solid 6
out of ten then we got Nick Cage
Superman bumped it up to a solid nine
that's what happens would you get your
little cameo in there let's hit this hit
the thing oh my God you're right okay
what are we at we got tenor we got a
tenor run ferry run to the super chats
then we got a Decay Superman also
thoughts on who Batman could be in
Batman and the Brave and the ball to
keep up the great work Nicholas Cage uh
God uh who would I think Clooney would
be a good Batman Beyond one I think it
would confuse people though I think 100
people would think it's the [__] like
oh this is to you for Batman or Rob I
think it would really confusing and
let's face it this is having a really
hard time at the Box obviously uh they
need a clean
uh so that
I don't know I haven't really I mean
look I'm as big mentality
I'm a big fan of the Jensen Ackles
choice I think that would be really
awesome casting honestly I think he
could pull it off really well I like
Jensen Ackles I like Milo vintamilia I
like I like Jakey Jake's uh it's
unlikely but I think Jake Gyllenhaal
would crush Bruce Wayne and a paternal
Batman I want to be dark and brooding
Jake Busey yes
the only problem is you'd recognize him
as soon as he smiles yeah who's Bruce
Wayne I don't know that creeper
oh my God
those are my big three nice good picks
alrighty here we go hold on one second
guys just gotta get real also George
Clooney's not gonna be the Batman of the
bird in the bold because that ending
implies that he's in Another Universe
therefore allowing the cake and eat it
too of either bringing Ezra back or not
so that is a separate Universe by the
Canon of the movie itself that's not
saying that that's again guns uh Ezra's
coming back hold on guys we're so far in
the Stream you're just gonna watch me
refresh it just to check just checking
things to make sure we are staying on
track today and Bam pal bang uh does not
matter raise Batman because that's
staying in elseworld along with Joker
because that's going to stay a more
serious tone it wouldn't work if that
interacted with the greater Justice
League movies I found myself just
thinking about the Batman oh I can't
wait for the Batman today yeah I just
think he just woke up like man if the
Batman couldn't stop thinking about it
specifically the Batman I've been making
a video series on Tick Tock and YouTube
of uh like if you liked this read this
and they're doing well but the Batman
one was my most fun because I think the
tone of Matt Reeves is the closest to
the comics I like of Batman so I really
am excited for the way they're keeping
them separate let's see here Chris fine
as Batman you make him funny yeah I like
Christmas Charming dude Dungeons and
Dragons I can kind of see if he wasn't
so high profile oh Corey does not keep
up with anything uh you have like all
these movies and I try to keep up we do
so many less videos Mobius should have
showed up that would have been awesome
all righty we got some stream Labs
stream labs are awesome they take less
less fees from that sound effect and
considering that we just had uh Super
Mario blocked again by Universal the
same video no re-edits the same video
it's like that's the most third third
time's a charm he's like okay sure why
not they're they're struggling all of a
sudden it's weird when you appeal
something and then they go all right
it's fine and then go you know what we
changed their minds we're gonna block
you we just put fast X Out on on demand
we need to recoup this stuff
um let's see here Jaden Stevens
hey guys op Blake actually nope wrong
one you're right John my bad I mean not
to not honor I don't know you know a
previous stream I messed up op Blake
with the 10.
run Barry run to the super chats
the death of Barry's mom seemed targeted
and it seemed like they had planned on
killing her already it was a government
conspiracy to create the flash so I
don't get why his dad's staying home
actually changed whether or not she died
maybe not that same day but I feel like
she would have died regardless there's a
deleted scene confirmed where Ron
Livingston beats the [__] out of reverse
flash and why would he what would be the
motive in killing his wife so reverse
flash in the comics is talking about the
dad why was the dad convicted I don't
feel like they did enough justification
for why the dad was convicted uh I I
mean like he was the only one on the
scene no man it's always the husband and
no one else lives in their neighborhood
motive CSI man it's always a husband
that's why Ice-T comes in he's like
sucker
[Music]
he was mad because he had to go get a
can of tomatoes I hate her yeah yeah and
he showed back up and just stabbed her
when he came all Dante yeah
uh but yeah no I mean we know the the
reverse flashes he he wanted to create
flash yeah and that's why with Barry's
dad there it wouldn't have worked
because I think I've always seen it as
the mom dying is is doubly bad because
then the dad sitting in prison makes it
a longer pain like if the dad dies too
if they're gone whereas like dad's in
jail and then mom's dead that's a that's
a Perpetual so I think what the mom has
to be alone they must have cut out a
thing about him discovering that it was
like a reverse flower didn't know it was
reverse fly the way the show did it too
you know we're like what is that little
fuzzy yellow thing
and so they they must have they must
have cut that out because
it it just it just really raises the
question of like this guy would have
checked he would have checked to see who
killed his mom he has the ability to
just speed by and go hey Dappers
right there yeah
[Music]
the mailman
yeah
yeah uh let's see here Sammy boy Sammy
boy's got let's see where are we at
Sambo's got people we're gonna read
through them really quick yeah yeah yeah
okay all right here we go koi do your
speed reading love how we get a soft
origin story of flash we see how Barry
would have probably acted using his
powers for the first time I also love
the bvs and Flash have a grand
perspective of the fight of Zod and
Superman is the version the Battle of
New York
okay well done sir I did I did like
seeing oh yeah okay there's one thing I
do like about the Man of Steel stuff it
is seeing when Barry had his like yeah
shitty suit uh makeshift when he put
together and then I thought they were
gonna bring that around again with with
you know saving I didn't know if it'd be
like say the exact same dad or some [__]
but I thought they were gonna bring that
around with saving someone that kid and
his dad come back they just don't get
crazy yeah yeah it's just like oh
different rubbles so they're fine but I
think that was to emphasize the point of
how much it's gonna bother
Newberry when he can't save Ezra when he
can't save um you know Batman right I
think that was the purpose of that but I
I still thought it would come around in
a different way for um our berry I also
like the line like just say one that's a
Superman line so I like that flash
learned from Superman because they have
a lot of interactions in the Justice
League so there's like this classic
technically I'm sorry it's Batman
apologies I meant Batman there it is
yeah uh it's a good line as bad as the
movie is no we cannot give credit to
Joss Whedon for any singular thing not
even astonishing accent also somebody in
the chat said Johnny Depp Batman
which I don't want but would be fast
[__] had two here right yeah and then
just do a quick question
there's no time John love it with this
movie in the crisis event almost every
property has been acknowledged or
visited I heard people saw multiple
endings and screens before release were
there any changes to yours no we saw the
final version uh we went to the collider
fan screening and uh uh that was the
that was the first that was the first
place a complete one right yeah so we
saw with the ending and with the post
credit scene John Watts sitting in the
back row yeah behind us yeah yeah how
about the Primo he saw it his the other
Multiverse movie he didn't make it I
love that no way home is like Flashpoint
and like John Watts is behind us I was
like we're in the Multiverse I should
make sure he did it better
um
John Rita fast speed read as a DC fan I
got all the cameos but I think if you're
gonna do this why not give some love to
arrowverse Dark Knight the Batman things
fresh in people's minds heck the king of
cameos Ryan Reynolds his Green Lantern
would have been fun right we're running
a great point they will acknowledge the
arrowverse in like 20 years
when it's not what people really really
want yeah and it's Nostalgia I'm not
present no yeah and not when they're
canceling and ending like all of the
arrowvers do you see what Stephen Amell
said what he's they asked him if he'd
come back he's like well the way I see
it right now they need them more than
that they need us more than we need them
and I was like damn stop dude came out
as Arrow himself I mean he's got a he
loves his wrestling he's got the
wrestling attitude he does also I heard
he's a tough guy I've heard some stories
about dude he can actually do the salmon
ladder I've heard of behind the Seas
he's a tough guy I know his cousin
Robbie I want to get on his bad side
yeah there's no joke devotion in the
chat so skeet all riches DCU Batman all
right here we go oh and then shock here
also said
um uh where is it Shakir also sick coin
John have you seen RR if you did what
are your quick thoughts if not you
should it was a mind-blowing experience
back to flash I found the ccpd cast a
bit over the top goes to the same frame
letters that they came from another film
yeah they were whatever
it's a fun scene but you know kind of
fun uh I have seen RR I liked it but I
did not have the revelatory experience a
lot of people shared with me that it was
going to change my life I did like it uh
I reviewed it on my my koi cast like my
podcast
um and I personally found it to be a
very good movie I think a lot like flash
I was told like Christ would come back
and hand me a trisket and he didn't so I
was like what the hell but you know um
whoa wait what were we just talking
about
RR The Flash Michael Keaton oh I love
the line of um
uh Top Gun with the gay guys oh it's so
good the gay guys playing boxes
well because like arguably if you had
Kevin Bacon in it it might have been
more open about his gayness because I
think Tom Cruise didn't want it to be as
gay because they toned down to the
gayness in the sequel so I feel like if
it was Kevin Bacon it might be gay or
which is impressive because top gun's
pretty gay okay loves them did I miss
there's there's someone here okay right
here Sharma making sure I got it yeah
uh the twist at the end was consistent
because it would have been a big plot
hole otherwise
yes the fact they still change something
with the camera yes was understandable
why but he showed he learned nothing so
yeah the fact that there were changes at
the end was satisfying sure yeah I would
agree with that no but like the main
thing was he still needed his mom to die
but he's not changing the the events
that came before his present time so it
is
yes he is he's changing where the cans
are and thus changing where his dad
pointed his head but that doesn't affect
anything until the present because that
doesn't the technology isn't established
till like like say it's 2024 that's
going to change something something once
you get to that point yeah but not until
then is what I'm saying what thing would
it change well that's why you have but
that's Batman says anything you change
is retro causal so it can change things
in the past and the future so I'm like
if you change anything well that's why
there's the consequence of of George
Clooney yeah I'm just saying it it I I'm
kind of confused as to why Barry did
that because he just learned why you
shouldn't do that and how much you can
affect the past as well it's because the
main thing he wanted was just to get his
dad out of prison I get why he did it
but I I think it does negate the lesson
being learned I think he learned that
because he chooses to do it it's not
like it's an accident there's two very
drastically different emotional
associations with the lessons though one
is your mom [__] dies the other is
after my dad has been serving like
decades in prison he could finally get
he has to
yeah but it doesn't have the same
consequences or Ripple like they're
they're much less but I feel like the
the lesson learned is you should assume
there will be consequences you shouldn't
be surprised when George Clooney shows
up then
I think he thought the consequence would
only occur if you interact with someone
because he kept repeating like no
interactivity no interaction he kept
repeating like the person so I think the
the lesson wasn't learned in the right
direction that he should have he
shouldn't have done anything but in
doing that small thing now if there's a
sequel it would be you know establishing
like you know not even that something
small yeah
yeah but I feel like that's what he
where he started in the first place was
I'm just gonna put the can in the cart
that's something small I don't have to
talk to anybody and sure he does sure
but it's still just as small of a thing
he's still learned that he has to let go
and accept what happened to his mom
which is something he has been able to
do this whole time
true I just think that he doesn't I
think that's what happens to his dad
and there's no and yeah no lives are
lost or game and a smaller risk yeah I
think it's a it's a smaller risk of a
thing because there's literally yeah and
and because of the the footage not being
available until a certain amount of time
it doesn't change 20 years worth of
stuff it changes the present which is a
small technology had to fix that so to
me it worked that it was a song this one
person it's just uh yeah I don't know
the Retro causal thing is
it seems like a big risk to me just
because it seems like you could mess up
the past as well as get your desired
future effect yeah because they do
explain that clear I I get it it's more
precise I understand that the reasoning
is better but I'm also like the way it's
communicate I'm like well you just can't
change anything thanks with you too
without completely changing the timeline
it's all like I don't even believe this
point I just wanted people to agree with
it
it's good to feel agreed with
uh but good I'm glad I'm glad that works
better for you guys all right happy
that's good no we got this guys you're
so Money Baby Ryan Philippi is guns
Batman interesting call Auburn closes
Catwoman is great
uh
yeah our current choices change our past
of that Multiverse like the current
Choice it's retro causal that's why
Bruce was older it's not the butterfly
effect it is it is it impacts in all
directions because it's a Multiverse
yeah and he even says like more than
just the past yeah just multiple
directions
agreeing with us I'm good for now uh and
people I got the chat on my side I can I
can Levy them against you
attack chat to my bidding
um Jonah Hill is Superman uh that's a
tattoo joke that is a good tattoo joke
tattoo all right let me adjust this let
me adjust this one second one second I
like that he lived across the street
from Grayson's that was nice yeah I like
that too yeah snacks and Cinema
a whole CGI budget went into that Nick
Cage fight it was a cool flight at least
they had him have a cool fight that's
made more rewarding instead of just have
them turn and look
I did like that Nick Cage fight yeah I
didn't I completely forgot about the
spider it had to be explained to me all
over again I was like oh I didn't know I
was like that's not you like going doing
anything they didn't even show Nick Cage
yet now he's already losing my mind I
don't know what that means
yeah when I saw his hair I was like
they're not gonna are they oh my God
I was overjoyed in that moment do we do
we get the Bucky one or no
the what the Bucky's super
uh no no thank you John oh we got a few
Derek couldn't get either
did we get the kids okay because I
didn't no no we didn't you're right okay
[__] now here everyone it's all good
it's all good so yeah it was after Corey
making sure okay okay okay all right
Derek Washington says Nick Cage looked
Godly I did like the way he looked too
she may look real you gave him this yeah
go down again do we do we skip to get to
these other Cory M's that's all I want
to know is like did we do Joe here yeah
because he said the solid nine and we
cast Jensen apples daddy Clooney all
right cool he did look Godly and and and
like I get that they needed the
consistency I I I want to see his real
face but I was that was for me one of
those moments where like this fan
service is working I don't care if it's
CGI I'm just glad we got to see a
glimpse of it because that's something I
actually didn't think they would ever do
they should have just put him there
de-aged because Nicholas Cage still
looks Botox ready he's he's still smooth
man yeah give him that wig and he'll be
fine all right Bucky Barnes yes I hope
we get reverse flash versus The Flash in
the sequel then we find out it was him
that killed Barry's mom then Cries Out
infinite Earth after that two just
massive massive flash movies in a row
and then after that we go to just
regular flash Adventures for the rest of
the French yes day to day villain of the
weeks wasn't the original ending
supposed to hint at the looming crisis
yeah the original ending before the
reset was a crisis movie I think would
have been the third kind of like you're
implying the sequel is going to be a
reverse flash but everything was leading
to crisis and then uh yeah there was a
real question Hamada wanted to do crisis
um but yeah no the original ending uh
that had Michael I remember seeing the
first thing I ever saw Michael Keenan
were the leaders yeah yeah which I was
like so I thought it was Michael Keaton
coming out of the car in that moment and
and uh and then when I was scattering
screenshots for uh the review uh that
you could on the final trailer they they
put in the deleted scene where there's
Cara in that same crowd I'm like oh
these are just the people those are the
same like group crap people when they
get them in Batman when uh like George
Clooney scene Cara's in the crowd ever I
mean yeah you can see the people behind
her oh regular people and then I and
then I heard that that was supposed to
be the car was supposed to be there too
it's like oh yeah yeah it's totally not
in the movie
but it's just funny how they still kept
it in the trailer though that's a good
like shot of her so it makes sense
um but yeah yep that uh I I guess
is they're like well if we we can't put
Michael Keaton let's just make it funny
let's do it funny
um well that's an interesting question
actually in the chat but we can get to
it a little later RoboCop
did you guys notice the flim overhead
Gotham when Barry arrived to the bridge
Gotham overall looks amazing as well set
in Glasgow they're always going to
Glasgow for gossip she did a film there
man cheaper to film and older film older
architecture probably too Carl Urban
would be a great Batman uh but no I did
not notice this blimp did you guys I did
not know but it's very Batman of them
thank you for level cop I will look for
a blimp in my third viewing also now I
really loved red Batman because the
scowl is the same Carl Urban it'd be
great yeah he'll just have his whole
mouth
I thought the uh Aquaman post-credits
scene was a big waste of time I thought
they could have deleted they should have
deleted it does anything for the movie I
thought they were gonna make him Lobo at
that moment or something right to give
it a a purpose yeah and to have him be
just super drunk for a better reason but
like I don't know Mustafa jav
yeah that was a good line amongst the
chaos yeah
for Jack Reacher two Jack Runner Jack
swimmer Jack [__] Jack Slayer Jack the
riper Jack kisser Jack shooter Jack
reachera basically uh on our Reacher
reactions we were always trying to find
like
punser's name got it Jack reach around
it's really funny then I like that word
play reach or word play a little little
Jack before Jack reached around when I
was reviewing the Tom Cruise once well
excuse me it's pretty funny
[Laughter]
we'll keep that in mind for season two
absolutely recited so good I love that
young boy yeah that guy's great so big
he's huge he was a fast X in the
premiere and made everyone look so tiny
and though it's not a small cast well
gracian I think that's what James Gunn's
doing he's going to slow [__] down
instead of wanting to hop to the big
ones hold on
Marco
tunstitious
cut myself off how could you run Barry
run to the super chats that's the first
time someone says run Berry run in the
show uh I really enjoyed the movie but I
feel like bat Fleck didn't serve much
Purpose with big chase scene no I was
just fun fan service yeah it was just a
date like is it starting out with a
normal day in Gotham I'll use this
opportunity to say that I thought the
food thing would come back around
uh because and I really like the awkward
um Stakes of the fact that Barry needs
to eat don't know why he didn't pick up
the candy bar in the beginning when it
doesn't make sense okay you're the
fastest guy yeah
I don't know what he lost about it just
pick up some candy bars right there you
could have gone up a blip and still bit
Yeah like it still would work as a
regular human I would have had the time
let's go pick up the candy bars
I needed like the super fast powers to
do it yeah
um but I I do like that uh that that
seems like such a big thing for him then
in the finale of the movie
like oh I guess he doesn't need to eat
neither of them need to eat because
they've been doing it for days yeah you
guys think I've been doing this so long
I'm like yeah yeah I thought that would
come around but I did like uh the
badflick actions I don't I feel like
it's not entirely necessary sure but it
is fun it's good to establish just how
pretty bad in the world because it seems
like they're they're putting this thing
where flash is not respected he's not
really lighting people and people are no
one even thinks I mean even has that
part is like yeah thanks flash so I
thought they were gonna have some wrap
around where like flash becomes the hero
or something yeah celebrity recognized
uh so yeah those are the things that
they like set up that don't ultimately
get paid off uh who knows that's what
part twos are for uh so yeah snacks and
Cinema back at it in the chat I was
fully expecting Aquaman to pop up when
Batman was hanging off the bridge in the
opening fight sequence uh you pointed
out something about these Wonder Woman
cameos use this opportunity to uh say
what you told me the other day about how
you feel Wonder Woman cam is a little
strange you got well yeah 45 seconds
that's right I think the Wonder Woman
cameos are Charming but this and Shazam
both had this like strange quality where
she shows up and she's just like oh
you've got like it's it's she has this
like it's it's so light in a way that
didn't quite complement the scene and
she's like so spotless she just feels
like she's kind of completely elsewhere
and uh and I don't I don't know to be
like the one major Cameo that you get in
the film was like a little peculiar in
that sense because it's like it's badass
when she shows up but also it is like I
don't know there's something
I probably articulated it better before
but yeah there's something just sort of
like
sillier about her presence that kind of
took me out of it for the moment I like
the lasso of Truth jokes I think those
are fun but uh yeah I don't know there's
there's something
as like artificial almost feeling even
though she is like the one real Cameo
when she shows up yeah it's a yeah it's
an odd beat
uh someone just around the chat I just
want to if this is true it was reported
an hour ago that gun is currently screen
testing Nicholas Holt Dave corn sweat
Tim Brittany and uh everyone in wardrobe
I know they're screen testing uh but I I
had not heard the uh I think it's down
to three for Lois and Superman but I had
another wardrobe that's exciting yeah
we'll just wait
we'll just wait all these like people
are like dying for news right now that
could happen while we have our panel on
Saturday at Comic that'd be awesome
I do think Wonder Woman deserve better
cameos I I think she did this was more
of service in the Shazam one yeah yeah
that was way more perfect if you like
that movie it makes more sense I thought
she was better there it made more sense
even though she was like CGI or some
[__] I just wonder if you're there I
just wanted to be more part of the scene
because she's just kind of standing
there grinning yeah
look at me being here yeah I don't know
it's just like it's cute in a weird way
to me that's like sacker and sweet yeah
yeah Bucky Barnes Atlanta thank you
Bucky hey guys if you're still here can
you leave the like oh yeah I wonder if
we can Fly and Ride the Lightning she
could have got there earlier if someone
pointed out in the chat uh when Iris was
talking to Barry at night the building
she was standing in front of was called
Grayson's anyone else see that yeah John
certainly did yeah he pointed it out
earlier you got a Super Chat earlier
yeah if you want to make sure John
doesn't talk about something ahead of
time doe eyes we got a a cat here it's a
smiling smiling cat hell's yeah
koi Flex
is that the cat Emoji yeah spider koi
what I like to do is Splash chemical on
you and then get hit by lightning just
to get powers apparently that's all it
takes it could have explained something
with like Barry's DNA too so that way
because apparently could anyone do this
yeah anyone in that lab you could have
brought 10 people and got 10 flashes
this gets the chemicals again it's
electrocuted again yeah that's what
should really patent that it's really
important it's funny it's funny stuff
save but comedy is what we call
Hollywood these days uh Alonso payee
Alonzo P oh my God hey
run Barry run to the super chats I was
hoping to get a Zack Snyder's Justice
League speed force type scene not in a
movie that has to jam pack all this
still my favorite sequence still enjoy
the movie that what did you do delivery
from Supergirl
oh she plays an intense Supergirl really
well yeah this is the most comic
accurate Supergirl I've ever seen I love
that like Supergirls yeah 100 I will
find her so Supergirl in the comics is
like raised on an asteroid alone
isolated and then she's not it's all a
commentary on nature versus
yeah I do one okay nature versus nurture
like without mon pocket what does a
Kryptonian become so I love the idea
that even without that the kryptonians
are so full of hope that they're able to
actually be beyond the nature versus
nurture so Cara represents what it's
like to not have that Clark Kent Kansas
upbringing so the fact that
you're able to still convey the fact
that you can have also would be full of
Hope which is the actual metaphor of
what that s represents so the joke is
this s doesn't stand for super it stands
for hope it actually works if you have
the dichotomy and The Duality of
Superman versus Supergirl and I think
that Cara here plays her better than
like what they have to do with Benoist
or what they had to do with Helen Slater
and I think she actually gets the
character more fully
I don't know who
um it was the Oscars fan favorite movie
about this Janine is correct 15 minutes
what did I yell about
berries are being thrown out the window
that's right guys you heard it here on
my 15 minute rant Spidey Sensei 72 thank
you thoughts on deleted scene about
Batman quitting
what what which Batman quit in which
time Batman quit
what and how does he do it is he just
like listen I'm gonna get a real job
now we have 30 seconds to wait to hear
that man quit because I have no idea
what's the beat yeah if somebody knows
uh you know Enlighten us I think it
would have been funny if Ben Affleck got
in his car and then just drove it
straight into a wall
um
burned down the manor oh my God yeah
Patrick Star the S is for Superman
Christopher Reef said so they should do
a Multiverse movie where they all do get
together they talk about it what does
your S stand for spaghetti yeah
[Music]
spaghetti spaghetti Flash and then Slash
from you know the band and his stands
for slash uh I think that it is in that
continuity Superman but like Christopher
Eve is uh not the comic book it's just
different continents Keaton shows up at
the fight with the kryptonians that says
yeah I give up that's not true that's
not true all right Aisha Kenya thank you
Aisha for being here
but you said in the chair you hadn't
seen the movie I know Brandon well
Brandon routes acknowledged in the TV
show he blocks the arrowverse now yeah
no question just want to let you
handsome fellows know y'all are awesome
I've been loving the content keep up the
great work guys oh it's so nice for you
to say especially when it's a lady who
says it it's really guys who are just
saying it to me and then all the women
say it to John and then Coy gets real
private DMS you know what I'm saying
okay
and yeah it was a bummer that they
didn't do Val or Brandon Ralph I guess
too I'm in gring Gustin I think would
have been the biggest moment but I do I
acknowledge they did it on the show it
just would have been nice to see Grant
here whatever he hates the flash now
it's why he quit
um rco
think about it everyone think about it
the conclusion to Cadence Batman is him
uh-huh Supergirl failing to save Earth I
don't know hello I'm getting Terminator
dark fate John Connor vibes why it's not
like Keaton just showed up and they
killed him
not like they put the ending in the
trailer yeah and it's not like it's like
a weird I don't know not retcon but it
does kind of affect the the previous
Cannon whereas this is just yeah this is
an event that wasn't supposed to happen
so you guys are both gonna fail at this
and this universe is gonna fold up you
still get a substantial amount of time
with them so I don't feel the same I
mean they're saying that he's still
saved right now but it's a different one
because it's George Clooney exactly
Multiverse yeah God damn it damn the
Multiverse it's confusing the DCU is
gonna be so confusing and James Gunn was
like this is the greatest superhero
movie ever I'm based in my whole DC
Universe off of how great this is Alex
segalo what is it koi very quick no it's
very quick I will say that the only
might be good thing about Flash on doing
as well is that much Yeti is already
getting rewarded with Batman and if this
doesn't do well they're more likely to
just clean slate the DC if that's not
done well they might have like I think
it's gonna be less messy because of this
weekend yeah good thing it's failing
that's what we all wanted to hear Alexis
[Laughter]
did you like bath Flex voice used in the
flash his speaking voice when he is just
talking with Barry I thought was great I
really like uh I don't feel like has
pointed out enough we were kind of
touching on it earlier this movie does
do a good job at distinguishing between
Ben Affleck and Michael Keaton's Batman
interpretations because Michael Keaton
just like so chill so chill he's like a
stoner
I guess thinking the dude he does look
like he is in the opening scene I'm like
that guy's got rugs that tie the room
together this is such a chill laid-back
guy his Joker came in and pissed on his
rug like he's lost a lot of that
Darkness for sure
um but it you can feel that that the
past Darkness it is I was just like hey
man this is just life now
and now when he wants to get nuts he's
got a bowl of macadamia I really I think
that is Batman ultimately necessary in
here I think there's ways they could
have tweaked the writing to make him
feel more essential the way how
Flashpoint comic and in the DC animated
makes Batman feel very essential in that
story there's basically could have
tweaked it to to alleviate any question
Beyond reasonable doubt that Batman was
necessary to be in this movie
um but I think Michael Keaton's
performance is it's so charismatic and
it's so enjoyable that I'm like yeah I I
prefer him in it because he's so he's
just so much fun he is he's uh both
times watching this I'm like Keaton
really helped save whatever the writing
because even when he chooses to be
Batman
I go
what's the what there's not a moment to
be like oh that's the strong why in
motive that makes him go I'm going to
Don the cape after so many years you
know it's just it just kind of happens
it really seems like he's got nothing
else to do brush past it like there's a
little bit of a punch with the whole
Alfred reminding and he's been watching
him but again that comes back to the
thing I was saying earlier that there's
a lot of things that I feel are rushed
through so it just becomes Batman it
doesn't feel it's like rewarding or as
cathartic as it ought to be but then at
the end when he dies I do that moment
yeah no but the moment he says like you
brought me back that that was the moment
we didn't get earlier yeah so I still
felt served did we notice the Laughing
bag you mean when the camera decides to
focus on it
yeah we know it's a laughing did you
notice this heavily features
hold on raccoon
for a 20. you want to get nothing
[Applause]
I find it interesting it's funny every
time it's spider-verse and Flash have
exact the promise I come up with these
at the such a last minute
week in advance I didn't come up with
them like at least the night before I
find it interesting that spider-verse
and Flash have exact opposite views and
the same sort of idea of Canon events
and they both came out so close to each
other now if only we can get them to
cross over I think this is a very
beautiful thing because I think
Spider-Man represents with great power
there must also come great
responsibility which is misquoted in the
Samurai movies which is part of why I
don't like them as much as other people
do there's an action required it's not
with great power comes great
responsibility it's with great power
there must also come it's an action it's
a verb it's a doing and it goes dun dun
dun dun dun dun dun dun get to your
point I I want I was but in Marvel
there's our Underdog characters that
have to overcome something in order to
succeed in DC these are gods that live
amongst us those are very different
views on what heroism is is so I like
that in the Spider-Man lore which is
more traditionally like I lose
everything this is what my life is I
have to do this miles is going outside
of that and going like I'm gonna change
things which is very unlike that
character of Spider-Man the archetypal
Spider-Man flash is going against the
archetype of DC which is yeah these
things are happening I'm I'm an
all-powerful being I have to fix it I
have to fix it this will change so flash
has to let go and Miles has to not let
go so I love that the candid events are
opposing and they're also juxtaposing
the expectations of the universe
themselves I think this is very
intentional and I really like that
they're so close together for sure
hahaha
[Laughter]
oh Smokey the Bear
run Barry run to the super chats yes did
anyone else say what the [__] when they
say when they say George Clooney yeah
the flash did yeah
I did
when we first saw the movie we talked
plain about this uh Cameo we first saw
the movie
um I I think I leaned over to you about
like an hour and I'd be like I guess his
tooth is just gonna stale
I know I was like so when they brought
it back at the very end and I was like
all right well that's a long game a very
long game for that joke yeah yeah
because at first when it goes into his
mouth I'm like this is the weirdest
little bit and then yeah and then it has
a little three yeah three beats it's
good I'll allow it because I didn't
forget about that tooth I was the most
kept thinking about like every 15
minutes like without work do people do
that would you have to dry your gums
severely or how yeah what's the science
here I know people like super glue
superficial but usually it's like half a
truth his truth anyway yeah of warden
the major villain I believe that he
became is not dark flash but the movie
version of savitar I I thought sabotage
okay a lot of people thought it might
have been Zoom when he first is
introduced
but I was like we don't have time for
Zoom It's gotta be it's gotta be
um another version of Barry that is
paying for the consequences like right
away
what does help like clue me into that is
the fact that I did see the whole
savitar season of I haven't read any
Saboteur Comics like this guy uh I've
only I only saw the whole season
dedicated to it so which was a season
that was like kind of up and down but
there were some really great moments
um it's when they do like Toby McGuire
dark Flash oh dude I say I haven't seen
the show that's like oh it's kind of
goofy but but I like Savage does he
dance he's got the emo thing going uh
but I do like I I but I but yeah it was
um it was it was fine I thought it was
fine I like what it represents in the
movie and I don't think the handling of
it but there are some structural things
that I do wish were yeah it was very
predictable uh but I do wish there were
some structural things that were a
little bit more fleshed out because
I did forget about it entirely until
like close to the finale when the
movie's like hey don't forget this guy
when he's waking up after being
electrocuted when Supergirl takes him up
and it's just like a quick flash of the
of that guy and you're like don't forget
that guy if he's gonna come here don't
forget about it this is important
I did like the concept of that that
whole when young Barry first phases with
the big pieces yeah and then it becomes
like a weapon like this is a cool like
horrific idea for that character and I
did think the phasing was really cool
too I actually like when they break it
down to a molecular level when they go
through the door when they're first
going into
um the Central City police station and
that humor works for me so I think that
beer is such a funny joke that beer joke
I laughed I I embarrassed myself I
laughed so hard when he first runs when
he doesn't have his powers oh my God
that little police is making it's making
fun of the way he runs that's the choice
yeah does It capture it in a way where
and then the overhead it's just you see
how silly it does look and like the fact
that there are willing to make fun of
that right on screen I thought it was
great that was really funny and it's
great because it's funny when he's in
the actual speed force you see it and
you go okay I guess with how fast the
wind must be I get that this must be
aerodynamics and then yeah you see it
normally I do like the stance that he
gets when he and he is to post too like
I think even Zach Sanders Justice League
it has the whole like preparation he's
kind of doing like Tai Chi oh yeah which
I think really helps establish that too
deep thank you the opening scene of
Batman chasing has guys reminding me of
JLA uh that Fleck is a MF tank dude got
thrown into cars and walls it didn't
Flinch it's the suit all saved by the
suit also Affleck's a beast so if anyone
if any of the Batmans I do buy Affleck
just being able to hang that guy's a
huge he is really tall like I was joking
before we he was getting out of uh his
little like limo to walk in and it's
second we were walking it was so funny
arrived and and it was like right where
we you were so we were like three feet
from what appeared in our minds as Bruce
Wayne I didn't see Ben Affleck I saw at
a Premiere Bruce Wayne appear and it
felt like the scene in uh which one was
it I had J-Lo next to him I don't even I
don't think I saw James I think I even
looked at him one of the most beautiful
people in the world in front of us we
literally got all our activities
don't even think I saw one of the most
beautiful people I've ever seen I only
know because of photos Olivia asked you
like what did Jayla look like a person
I'm like I don't think I looked at it
and we got stuck behind him we were like
within three feet of them I was like oh
Jayla was there yeah and I was and then
I I did get to thank Ben Affleck for all
of his service to Boston which was nice
that was a good moment for me but but
for a moment it was Bruce Wayne I had a
moment I had a real a very real moment
where
Ben Affleck was about to walk past us
and I was like koi do I get out my
camera he's like yeah get your camera
out so I got out my camera I started
recording about 10 seconds into
recording he did a quick glance at me
and I panicked because I saw every
online video I've ever seen of Ben
Affleck upset at people recording him
and even though this is a Premiere
totally different situation than like
getting donuts like a completely
different thing he's expected to be
recorded by everyone but the fact that
he looked right at my camera for a split
second I was like oh my God I was gonna
yell at me my favorite thing was I
didn't understand the context of you
taking out your phone so like really I
was like yeah we're gonna go in but then
when I saw what you were referring to I
was like he might thump you like he's
just so big and then like when I thanked
him I saw a bunch of people taking
photos with him and I was like I just
want to thank him for what he's done for
Boston but in that 30 second interaction
I was like I've never been more afraid
to say hi to anyone in my life and then
like he fix your hand and smiles and
you're like is this a trick like he's
just so intimidating he's such a Frank
Miller Batman and he's so kind but man
is that guy intimidating yeah you no
longer has bad side I've seen him on
that one yeah
Chef C
Chef Zee
koi what's the zipper do a ranking of
your most hated huh oh yeah Canadian
money is worth more than American money
yeah yeah oh
[__] that super chat's huge nice
do you guys know where that moment's
from
no when he sees the Batmobile
oh yeah that's not my voice that's
Ezra's voice it Blends beautifully
koi do a ranking of your most hated MCU
movies please no one's more likely to do
a negative video than koi I can
appreciate all MC movies for their place
but some do better than others crap [__]
talk only it's not very Canadian I think
it would be a great video we did a
negative video we did one and that's all
I that's like oh my god what have I done
okay he started twitching it did take
four times as long to film uh I have
things like for me I can't make art that
is to this scale so why would I [__]
talk it too there are a million negative
reviewers to every one positive one so
there's plenty of [__] you can find
three uh yeah I could be twice to five
times as successful tomorrow if I start
doing negative stuff but I quit talking
bitching about your lack of success take
your Twitter energy and put it on you to
start becoming yeah the only thing I
hate is hate so I will come at you troll
[__] but I will not come at Art
because art existing is a miracle so uh
the worst DC movie he's just the worst
Marvel movies uh I think that that
Captain Marvel looks cheap and uh it was
underserving to both Brie Larson and the
directors I think that movie did not do
justice to what Bree can bring and I
think the Marvel's gonna be a lot better
for it that's what we have in store I
think uh the Marvel's gonna be a great
way to show what Captain Marvel can be
but the movie didn't serve her uh I do
think Thor dark World meandered when it
had a purpose but there was a studio
interference level because it was the
first sequel that really didn't know
where to land things uh I think what
other ones are on the bottom of the of
the totem pole I think uh Hawkeye didn't
do Kingpin justice but the overall show
was good one division sixth episode is
not as good as one through five but like
these are all nitpicks overall art is a
miracle to exist and I don't think
negativity has a purpose in this case in
this setting
um it does those were negatives I did it
when it look at that movie We're not
gonna get views off of that um
well this one they asked and also those
were very like lightning to get your red
eye wide eye thumbnails scream about
virtue signal oh right
I know DC movies don't really flow and
connect like Marvels do but what do you
guys think the next movie or main focus
should be about in the DC EU uh crisis
on infinite Earths right away right away
I think I think this start off for
Christ I think that's what creature
Commander should be about The Crisis
crisis on infinite Earths uh that would
be the most important part of the DC EU
you got to establish it right away I
think opening scene of I think the final
scene of the first episode you should
see apocalypse showing up yes that would
be cool not apocalypse Dark Side dark
side yeah Dark Side crossover X-Men yeah
Marvel DC it's finally happened yeah
show have him show now that'd be awesome
ready the Armada they should even say
ready they are motto just to piss off
everyone who loved they should call
things what ifs instead of elseworlds I
think we're going to get a very cohesive
um DCU because it is going to be not all
connected I think the things that
connect are gonna work I think it's also
going to be much more plotted the next
10 years are going to be like
orchestrated versus like this than this
and then it's not gonna be as
reactionary I don't think we'll see you
know James Gunn like I do
lack of confidence that guy doesn't know
his Comics
um
of course Greg would like this movie I
feel like I've been the most negative
yeah Greg
would you just stop chilling honestly
hates the ending though I liked it I'm
just saying it is a little bit of an odd
choice
to the super chats yes Alan Wing John
reading Alan Ling I saw both Flash and
Elemental this weekend I had a better
time watching Elemental over flash I
liked flash but I didn't love it will
you guys save watching Elemental for the
channel I've heard it's not that great
So based off of the one opinion I heard
I'm gonna skip now one person said uh
it's uh I don't I don't know yet uh
maybe depends if it makes a splash uh I
haven't seen Little Mermaid yet nor have
I and like Elementals on that list too I
I mean I love Pixar Pixar's one of my
favorite Studios I feel like they just
don't Market them well anymore sorry Jen
some reacting to a Little Mermaid here
with my wife oh oh fun we should do two
we should do a koi and John and a
marriage these two dudes I want to hear
your racist Slanders the whole time I do
hate fish yeah
oh that's my real struggle when I think
of uh what's the name with the trident
that's King Triton but I think a Korean
Titan's gonna have a white beard white
man that's my issue I just hope that
there's a clipping song that Sebastian
gets to sing because he's so happy it
feels like a Will Smith escort where
it's like the the king of the sea makes
all the songs for like Little Mermaid I
just I just love how how ex how people
you know like David Diggs is is a very
you know gregarious and lovely presence
and yet when you go check out like his
band it's like the harshest yeah
dissonant dark
[__] take me on Twitter it's an outlet I
love it you need an outlet clipping all
day if you haven't heard clipping go
listen to some clipping highly recommend
good [__] also the blind spotting
soundtrack I gotta see blind spot so
good very excited Greg's like why are
they still talking
yep
Mr spaz world is here small note I hated
the lighting on Batman
just any scene like I'm supposed to be
sad this guy is dead and all I can
concern it on is the fact I can see his
nostrils who's dead
got it got it I mean
I thought I thought Michael Keaton
looked uh his Batman looked great in the
day uh it was Ben Affleck's when he's
just standing on the freeway that I
didn't like I didn't like the way any of
that looks I think it looks terrible
thing is really bad
um but I know you can capture him during
the day like you see it in Zack Snyder's
Justice League you can capture Batman
during the day Nolan's Batman was
daytime in the Target Rises like Dark
Knight Rises almost all day time I'm
saying I'm saying specifically Ben
Affleck's Batman he could even really
capture um because they they do make a
joke like what's he doing out during the
day yeah um but you know
love how bad Affleck's Batman just
refuses to uh
thank Barry for the uh Miracles yeah I
think it's so good I'm doing real Deeds
my ego wouldn't allowed me to accept
saved you just saved a bunch of babies
uh you have actual superpowers pop
admire fact
you could have done both really yeah
and maybe with less destruction I've got
to go save the world I'm Batman Bob
admire uh did they acknowledge Zack
Snyder's Justice League as Canon uh sort
of because Ben mentioned him going back
in time by one second what he did in
that that is their way of acknowledging
that Zack's under chest thing is Canon I
remember there was something that they
do say that Jason Clemens says uh we met
I think it was in her dream and that
takes place in Snyder's cut yeah that
whole sequence is only in Snyder's yes
so that implied that yeah yeah they're
they're a definite
to me this is the con uh following in
that continuity for sure um between the
two until I think it's worth watching
yeah yeah definitely everyone's
opinion's been different yeah I don't
think I've seen a movie this polarizing
in a long time it's like there's no one
that likes it you either really like it
love it or really hate it there's no one
that's like it's a five like it's all
sevens to tens and twos it's kind of
like Multiverse Madness yeah bass
Creek's child what up bass Creek's child
bet oh
run ferry run to the super chats
thoughts on them bringing back George
and Christopher Reeves I thought it was
pretty disgusting and pretty cool to do
especially with George a person whose
life was ruined by Superman yeah we
talked about it earlier in the Stream
and uh I think what Coy said was he's
dead his opinion doesn't matter so let
it let it be is that what he said does
worm food even get a vote is what I said
[Laughter]
I honestly think it's a really dangerous
precedent and I honestly think George
Reeves uh may or may not have killed
himself because of the impact Superman
had in his life so to specifically bring
him back as Superman feels like burying
him and unbearing him and burying him
and unbearing him twice it is it is a
very uh slippery slope or entering with
using the likeness of the dead and a lot
of the reason the strike is happening is
because the writers and sag don't have
anything in their contract about AI
That's cool but uh right now we're
basically we're fighting the unions are
fighting for the right for the dead
because AI could actually have the
likeness of these things that don't have
the contract signed allow for this and
right now a lot of contracts are uh your
likeness in perpetuity throughout the
Universe which means like in 100 years
on Mars they can air you as an
unanimated it reanimated corpse so it's
a really dangerous precedent and this
movie using it in so many different ways
is kind of the first marker of like this
is where it could go so it I think it is
a detriment to society and I do think
it's a dangerous thing and I do feel for
uh the Reeves I also think it's very
uncanny valley-ish to use imagery that
is only in 2D in a way that is 3D and
kind of like reanimate a corpse so
literally so I don't love it I didn't
personally think it was worth the fan
service I didn't mind the Nick Cage
because he's with us and said it it was
okay so in real life it's conflicting
because yeah it's like in some ways it's
paying on or and you know obviously in
some ways I'm like I like that they
start with George Reeves and and honor
that because most people think of
Christopher Reeve right but but and with
Christopher Reeve you're like okay well
he played the role so many times he
might be okay with that
um but yeah it's it's an odd question
and two uh what I just realized now is
that Ben Affleck played George in a
movie I should have they should have let
Ben Affleck do it I like it continuity
where Ben Affleck's not Batman he's
Superman but Barry's like what's
happening and guess who Ben Affleck was
banging in that movie Diane Lane his mom
Martha Kent
oh my God look at this revisify run
Barry run to the super chats moment of
silence thank you
oh look at that those are the best those
are the best yes
so you want to live stream
take the money don't say [__] just wait
there's a lurk so that might been off
the whole time
I want it to be off so that do anything
it doesn't uh suck battery
yeah more people are coming around to
you on the cans John I mean you know it
just it just creates a question in that
if you who cares travel never makes
sense don't think about it too hard it
fries your mind what are you saying that
you prefer you prefer that Ron
Livingston stay in prison Ron Livingston
is
done they should have moved the cans yep
Barry doesn't get to be there in court
when it happens he get he's he goes to
the courthouse they're like Barry your
dad's just been Presumed Innocent
because of the footage like no way
that's awesome Billy crudup
and he's like who are you yeah
that would have been great George
Clooney shows up how awesome would that
have been and then George Reeves
George Clooney from the ground
oh goodness gracious I heard a very
interesting George Reeves story I won't
go into right now
what what a setup what a teacher hold on
everyone
run Barry run to the super chats I'm in
the same boat with y'all Jorge and
nestores says I overlooked the negatives
uh yeah sometimes a movie can be just so
enjoyable that you can Overlook it and
then you could [__] on some [__] that's
the thing it's like there's logic and
emotion and the thing is at the movies
are like a feeling experience and
sometimes the movie can be so logically
annoying that it can override your
emotional experience but to me I just so
much it's easy to have fun with this one
I can still have fun and watch Justice
League and be like what a shitty movie
but it's fun
um I love the mom ending lost my mom and
it hit I understand man
she's amazing what a presence that Mom
has yeah she's so good like she needed
her to be that effective in those scenes
and I thought efficiently like really
well effective uh I like you believe her
even making a choice
when she is like hey I don't know you
I'm just a stranger may the Lord Jesus
Christ
when I was making the choice to like
console this stranger in the grocery
store you believe that she would do this
and that's incredible thing what a weird
thing someone no one would do that like
you believe she would do it from from
just the brief times you have with her
not enough people are talking about how
awesome of a performer she is Gene
cheater I want to see your flesh movie
uh yes that'd be amazing
um R.I.P to schnepp yes rest in peace
John schnepp yeah
Clooney got a big reaction in my theater
oh yeah dude that was great that's
that's the greatest one and then and
then you know then they just ended off
with a post-credits scene that's just
like the whole time you're watching it
going someone's gonna they're gonna say
something important
some Big's gonna happen I guess not okay
that was like some light comedy
on paste post-credits scene for what it
needed to be I'm wondering if that's the
thing that he shot Jason Momoa shot when
he was all like celebratory and he was
like yeah everything's working out I'm
on the lot remember there was that video
of him that it was like I bet he's Lobo
now I bet they shot that that day I
don't think
it's trying to get into the flash
you guys ain't ready for this [__] I've
been trying to get more comedy in these
movies
so good
run Barry run to the super chats I think
people are hating too much on this movie
Emmanuel Rodriguez says I think it was
really enjoyable fun and heartfelt it
was a Bittersweet goodbye to the old DCU
and I had a blast with it I really do
feel like it holds
holds a Nostalgia that you could feel
the nostalgic love it doesn't just feel
like
even though I don't like the Cameo use
it's strange to me even though I thought
the Illuminati was weirdly used in
Multiverse of Madness I thought they
could have done so much more with them
I somehow felt more of a touching
uh uh
you know what I'm trying to say yeah
there's something that felt more
heartfelt I think it's mushady man about
about even the weird cameos in here that
you're like the intent behind it feels
different yeah the intent doesn't feel
as ghoulish as like some of the ethical
concerns saying it out loud is way worse
in my head than what it is because the
heart feels there I don't think anyone
put George Reeves in there with Mal
intent it's just an odd thing because of
the history because you don't know the
history is just a cool moment but if you
do it's odd but I do think that even
those moments were from a good place I
agree the intent was clearly there you
guys are just basing your knowledge off
of the movie hollywoodland you don't
know anything yeah well
many times I also watched the BuzzFeed
unsolved yes
you want to get nothing
let's get nuts super chats yeah brodies
love the energy in each video and live
stream just want to say thank you for
all the laughs hearty heart heart I'm
watching The Flash tonight in spite all
the spoilers I'm still excited this is
one of those movies you can watch no
matter how many spoilers you get as
always you guys rock much love well I
hope you enjoy it appreciate you showing
your support and yeah I mean as much as
like the trailers I thought the trailers
because I did watch our old trailer
reactions I was like oh yeah no this is
like this pretty much went exactly like
how I thought it would go and then a
couple of the cameos were spoiled yeah
um you know uh some things so yeah for
the most I did I didn't hear anything
about like Supergirl dying and and uh
them trying to go back and fix I didn't
know any of that [__] right none of that
was spoiled for me at the very end
um and a lot of the details weren't
spoiled for me but I think that it's
like plot points that can be spoiled
that I'm still like nah it doesn't
really it didn't really it didn't affect
my I wasn't like watching it upstepping
just got room for me you know yeah I I
think that if I'd heard with all
definitiveness uh like the Spider-Man no
way home you know Toby's dick that
really that that leak uh affected some
things this did not have that same
impact of of like oh now it's lesser
yeah uh tjm has asked a few times in the
live chat uh do I want Scorpion or venom
for the next Spider-Man movie uh I think
Scorpio would be a much better
um street level villain I want
Spider-Man to be street level for a
while I think Tom Holland deserves a
friendly neighborhood in New York movie
I think Venom should be a Trilogy Where
the black suit comes in the second movie
and like you build to things so scorpion
would actually be the perfect one
because in the comic scorpion was uh
basically made by Jonah Jameson to hunt
Spider-Man that's a very contained story
you wanna have bad nipples let's get
some let's get fat nipples thank you
Jason the chat Johnny
ooh last room you've seen in real 3D
like 3D or not uh
Avatar Avatar
yeah both times I've seen it was Avatar
yeah both times I prefer 2D personally
but uh I want to see spider verse in 3D
but I don't know if I will but uh 3D and
Avatar's so good it is it's gorgeous was
Avatar Avatar was after Multiverse of uh
quantumania right yes it was December no
no no
it was okay then it would have been like
a year left no this is like two months
time but yeah quantumania then I guess
it would have been for me
um which it got better in three days it
looked better in 3D Tyler Fletcher I
understand thank you for the Super Chat
I understand the ending but also don't
what the hell
I know that's the way a lot of people
are feeling about it but don't worry
it's not going to matter DC resets every
other movie so don't you fret about it
even James Gunn's Gonna Keep that going
there's one thing I want James gonna
consistently do is constantly reset DCU
as often as you can every movie
just keep course correct the only
consistency is inconsistency
Groundhog Day Universe now
um I did I have a feeling General
audiences would not care about this
movie that much Boomstick Warrior
Boomstick a Boomstick Warrior Run Mary
run to the super chats yes
ant-man's director retroactively take
the CGI excuse from this movie I.E Modoc
looks like crap because that's how
Ant-Man perceives him
see I can understand the the intention
of like the speed force to me honestly
feels intentional not the cameos but the
uh I don't think it's an excuse I do
think mushitti set out for that look
like I think the psycho what is the
Drone but I keep getting the name of the
Chrono Chrono Bowl Chrono Bowl I do
think that was like how he perceived it
I think that was a goal yeah I get it I
I don't think though it comes it
immediately conveys to the audience so
that this is intentional I agree with
that which is why so many people are
bitching right all right I don't think
he's lying I just don't think it landed
the way he intended like the first time
it shows up I was like
oh no we talked about it like very
quickly that was one of our first talks
yeah and there's not a 100 consistency
of when
unless it only applies to the Chrono
ball there's not a 100 consistency of
how Barry sees figures in speed force
scenarios that's why I said the baby
people are real and sometimes they're
not
yeah well I think when he's seeing like
these different I don't know I just it
weirdly didn't
bother me because it it bothered me when
you're seeing like the when you're
literally looking at the other Universe
yeah and these other people it's like
you're watching a scene but when you're
watching like the slow motion
interpretation of reality yeah that
didn't bother me at all and I thought it
was kind of cool and psychedelic like
have you ever done like a heroic dose of
mushrooms the world kind of looks like
that I could kind of yeah the second
time around I could kind of see the idea
like yeah this this is like I don't know
I almost felt like if they'd made me
made them part of the sands of time that
Barry's standing or something that could
have helped like give them just sort of
a like a little Sandy Sheen or something
all right guys I'm gonna refresh these
I'm going to have to turn the super
chats off what
yeah never but we're gonna finish them
we're gonna finish them good I just want
them because we don't end the stream
without finishing everyone every single
one I just wanna I just gotta turn them
off and I want I want everyone here to
see what YouTube says
your fans will no longer see super chats
as a purchase option and you'll no
longer in revenue from it I understand
the implications of this action
Barry Allen wouldn't understand he moves
those cans we don't we don't move stick
around for the end of the stream I'm
gonna tell you my flash sex joke
I got a flash there's a one flash sex
joke sketch I've always wanted to make
good stick around to the end of the
stream if only Robot Chicken was still
making episodes you'll like it you'll
like it you'll like the sex show
somebody asked about please remind me
guys since the end you made a promise to
make to tell you my flashlight
yes it's a good one yeah wait wait let
me just check these don't worry guys I'm
Gonna Keep On Track
um even the movie's good the CGI is
pretty ugly
hey man it's rare where you can catch a
movie where you're like bad CGI but I
still had so much fun yeah all right we
got one stream Lab I wanna I wanna just
cross off bucket list here
wait in my entire life for this one
stream to happen and die without it
guys never leave the cave without it oh
my
God I'm like yeah
oh yeah I'm surprised you're the first
person to ask about this yeah I want
Pierce O3
uh he's asking well thank you for the
stream Lab what do you think they're
gonna do with the Ezra Miller flash now
just erase them and never mention them
again or a recast well because Ezra did
such a good job
I think we should just never talk about
anything again anything brought up my
favorite thing that keeps happening what
I love is that every Ezra Miller video
that we had done in the past
actually haven't done in a very very
very very long time but everyone we had
done in the past John was with me in all
those and yet there's this Camp of Ezra
Miller Defenders
who seek me out on social media well
there's an easy answer to that all the
time who are like when is Greg going to
acknowledge this stuff he said enjoy I'm
like man why aren't you guys looping
Johnny
because you tweet consistently that's
true that's true your page is more I
don't tweet about what happened to the
comments too I'm like
videos because you are the head you are
the face I'm just 50.
okay my thing is like there's these
people who have like gathered like
here's the insurmountable evidence that
everything you've ever heard on every
story is a lie that it's like what they
do yes and and uh I've I've gone through
it I'm like okay maybe sure yeah
um and then but then I'm always brought
back to this one question the same
question that comes up
why aren't the publicists and agents and
managers publishing any of this if this
is all completely accurate like why did
they chose the path of just shut up Ezra
Miller just shut up don't do it again
if this is all true why isn't the public
legal team doing any of this stuff that
apparently you people online can find
yeah this would be dream evidence I'm
not saying you're wrong and the numbers
are pretty staggering I get tweets that
are like 95 of it has been proven false
and that's a big number yeah
everyone right everything and especially
after watching with the Jonathan Majors
thing with them being like we have this
dubious evidence and we're just gonna
put it out there yeah you know you'd
think they would take any opportunity
with Ezra I will say I am very much team
like there should be a way to uh
prison isn't about living in prison it's
about like uh fixing things and I do
think that Rehabilitation yeah I do
think we're entering uh deeper into like
there is an unforgiveness pack made by
the public I think that we all like I
I'm not saying cancel culture I'm not a
comedian that just moved to Austin Texas
I am however saying that there is a an
instinct of certain people to be like
this is them going to jail and throw
away the key I would love to once we
find out actual fact and details to see
any sort of forgiveness and to see a if
there's Rehabilitation and I don't know
what that looks like I'm not in the
court system I'm not any of these things
so people getting mad at me for saying
in our video uh are reviewing this does
not condone or encourage the actions of
one Ezra Miller was meant to make levity
of a thing that we just don't know the
facts of I really really want Ezra to be
great I want that I would love for a
person to be happy every time I just
don't know what goes into what actually
happened and until we do it's not really
fair yeah same with Jonathan Majors we
don't know what actually happened it's
not really fair to make judgments at all
much less profit off them lots of
YouTube channels so I just I want Ezra
to uh be rehabilitated and I want Ezra
to be happy and I want uh you know any
of these things to have facts before
conjecture yeah
personally
but yeah I mean a lot of it just doesn't
it doesn't look good I mean we just
don't know
I've only seen one Tick Tock there's so
much smoke there's a lot of smoke there
must be some kind of Fire
but uh I I uh accountability is good I
think that it is a goddamn shame if they
absolutely choose to not talk about any
of it I agree because I do think this
movie has a lot of information when I
was like like pretty like it was like
good nope we need a
I still want your movie to come out
because a lot of people worked on it but
you don't have any other thing coming
out
if you get casting something else
upcoming
like we should come on we need to hear
something I I think there should be uh
you know statements made and I do think
I don't know how much this impacted the
box office I really don't I'm actually
surprised
that's why like I don't I'm surprised
that hasn't come up in these questions
and and I think that's a good thing and
I'm really I appreciate this audience
not making it about that like to be
honest it's about the movie and the fact
that that hasn't come up is is thank you
but uh you know we need facts I think as
they're working on themselves great
fantastic
um that's true you know it's just
there's some actions that especially
when we're talking about what was the
whole thing about the whole thing about
the grooming situation to me I'm like
that's an unforgivable if true yes
unforgivable yeah period
so Clarity do one interview
just one interview did you see anything
on the carpet I didn't see any yeah
there's one is there one there was one
that went out but I think that was it
okay yeah but that's just great in the
move oh my God impressive work I think
you guys was amazing in it all right
guys we gotta we're gonna we're gonna do
this we're gonna do this I'm gonna shift
gears at all
we're doing everything right now
everyone be quiet okay I'll sit silently
all right
here we go
oh yeah you can't refill them as
routines impossible impossible yeah
they're every frame
you imagine
CGI already as awful as it is
also I'm not sure another actor can
quite do that that was a truly
impressive performance like truly Tom
Hardy
I've seen that movie and I don't know
Ezra uh young Tom Hardy and and 30 year
old Tom Hardy uh
I love Tom Hardy Grant Gustin could have
done it
Chef C the guy who did it could have
done it Chef c u s Chef C says hold on a
sec hold on I've done messed everything
up in my life chaos
what are you doing man chaos
you want to get nothing let's get nuts
or to follow my other post an episode
with all of you on the MCU tropes
personal fatigues and annoyances that
you hope will change the MCU behind the
production nitty-gritty you wish they'd
be better at well maybe one day do a
video on that uh I think secret Invasion
which we all did have the privilege of
seeing with Samuel Jackson right next to
us the entire time staring right out so
it's the best thing Marvel's ever done
no that's not
um he was was not there
um but the um the I think secret evasion
is is the exact pivot for every
complaint you've ever heard
that was one more eyeball I wanna I want
you guys to tune in in the video to see
our panel of course where we put his out
there see what our opinion is I will say
that I was admittedly a little bit
surprised by the Rotten Tomatoes score
shocked it's been a while since I was
like shocked yes really and then I went
through it and I was like
are you the same people that complain
about the old emcee
all the things you claim to want this is
doing and it's doing it exceptionally in
my opinion yeah I put out a 50 second
thing because I didn't want to like you
know reveal too much of our opinion but
I was gobsmacked by the Rotten Tomatoes
I was a little bit surprised Ryan Clem
Ben's run marksberry run to the super
chats James Gunn recently said
spider-verse inspired him to pursue high
quality animated films for the DCU dope
which DC characters do you think LED
themselves to that format every single
one of them because especially there's
more of a Fantastical world to the DC
Universe than say the MCU actually or at
least with what James Gunn is starting
off with right now of course there's
Marvel characters that are absolutely
Fantastical I just think what the DC
direction that he's going is is a little
more Fantastical so I think any one of
them is so specifically Creature
Commandos that's the one I think he
should do a creature commando's animated
series oh oh what an idea I wonder if
he's gonna do something like that yeah I
think there's a lot of good DC
characters that could be uh like the
Green Lantern Corps I'd love to see you
know we're gonna get the two of them in
live action but there's so many members
of the core be cool to see an animated
Green Lantern uh I think that plastic
man really suits uh animation I'd love
to see that comedy translated to like
premium animation I think there's a lot
of really interesting justice league
dark implications I'd love to see
Constantine live action again but I also
would love to see certain things in the
world of Swamp Thing maybe not like so
Swamp Thing is is deserved of a live
action for sure but also deservative and
animated I think there are different
things you can do in each so there's a
lot of characters that would benefit
both and uh yeah I'm excited I would
love to see a polka dot Man origin story
horror Tale of that well and if you read
Swamp Thing the Alan Moore stuff it ends
so in a way that could not be filmed so
I'd really love to see some of the
things that like Alan Moore did with
Swamp Thing and animated we need to face
facts what are the fact thing is boring
these are lies lies and slander lies and
slander I just liked it in the chat
people have been sounding off what kind
of nuts they want to get yeah I saw
cashews and some honey roasted and also
I used to confirm or at least clarify
that I guess Ezra Miller gave their
interview on the carpet to a rep from
the studio
that's a safe place for them to have the
one talk guys be quiet
run ferry run to the super chats
raccoon shampoo thank you how do you
think DC will go about communicating to
General audience since the Superman
Legacy is a new thing James Gunn will
probably do some introduction in the
trailer how will they rebuild the box
office for lack of better wording
um big reason he had to recast is
because of that like you can't keep
Henry because of that yeah yeah that's
true I mean the fact that flash is not
doing well at the box office like it is
coming in under expectations and the
expectations were not even that high for
what for what this movie needs to profit
so I think it's one of the most
expensive movies of all time I know fast
X is the most expensive of the year
which might be the most expensive all
time this is like number three yeah uh
it's not looking good for the box office
whatsoever I mean the good thing is like
it's at least got two weeks to perform
well wait no when is Indy coming yeah
and he comes out in two weeks yeah so
it's got two weeks whereas like you know
these other movies had like Spider-Man
the Transformers right yeah so it's got
guardians it's got some time to perform
um however yeah like
and the critic and the audience scores
looking to come in at like a B plus yeah
not great uh because like even even the
rod Springs high score is like 85 so
you're like okay so maybe the audience
scores are going to be a BB Plus
so yeah uh I think
if there's there's never been more of a
sign now that like they need a fresh
restart for sure they've had two this
one is essentially a a sequel of sorts
um from Zack Snyder's Justice League or
any of the Justice League movies and
then Shazam 2 is terrible performance
and then Wonder Woman like no one saw
that in the theaters 84 for like some
apparent reason
oh the weirdest thing all Aussie Vlogs
I'm so proud of this Vincent D'Onofrio
wants to play Swamp Thing That was a koi
exclusive he gave me that uh during a
live panel interview at uh Megacon so I
was very proud of that it was a chance
stuff just [__] fluff your own self
huh
after getting that Swamp Thing but uh
yeah I think they're gonna make it very
clear the DCU is different I think
casting I love Henry Cavill I think you
have to make it very clear these are
different characters and I honestly like
I said earlier I think Flash not doing
well is going to mean Clean Slate not
rolling reboot hey John
Brian wants to know wouldn't the
supermarket wrestler receipt have proof
Barry's dad's alibi
oh my God yeah that is an excellent
point I thought that I didn't love
thinking of it he's always afraid to
bring up the negatives
canonically he crumpled the receipt up
and threw it away yeah way home that's
what Chloe would have said if we brought
it up early at the stream the Wormhole
he used all the receipts
the carbon paper wasn't made then and so
therefore yeah yeah yeah the ink faded
off really very fast in his pocket a
supermarket that I imagine they
regularly frequent couldn't there have
been some employee there
yeah yeah I was definitely there I saw
him at checkout
you know he could have had his own
receipt machine though you know for the
time to date it back in the 90s or so
when this would have taken place it
would have been cash set something not a
credit card which has a time stamp that
would have been cash that'd be harder
but maybe maybe the printer was broken
that's what reverse flash was busy doing
paper yeah like the Grinch he just like
takes all the paper there's only one
camera in that store
oh man
yeah that's a good point collided memory
100 correct the fact that movie doesn't
even have Barry contemplate checking who
killed his mom seemed odd to me
is right about whatever he said an hour
ago uh this movie of why why not
why did it do it I honestly if you know
who killed your mom you you cannot do
something about it you cannotes they're
the high risk items those are premium
organic tomato cancer are constantly
being [__] yeah we need security cameras
uh I want three cameras we spent the
store's whole Budget on this camera I
also like that it was run row of cans
not even like a stock they were like
these five green cans cannot be
disturbed yeah not the blue we don't
need Security on the blue ones just
three ones Andrew thanks Andrew for
being here saw this movie on 400
milligrams of THC and IMAX wow
love you guys the movie not so much
how much can you even properly assess
this movie yeah go back how'd you get
home go back and watch it with clear
eyes with eyes with your eyes open just
eyes four milligrams that's like I felt
terrified I don't do it I've been in the
sunken place I don't really do weed but
I know that's a big number
the highest I've ever gone is like 250
and that was a one time and I would
never do that again
it was a terrible experience yeah that
sounds dangerous story about it
sometimes dank
long story short I thought I was in uh
it's true because I was like freaking
out at a bar and it was in the uh people
were just laughing at me because I was
genuinely freaking out the whole time
you're Republic uh yeah I was terrible
I've just gone through uh I was going
through some hard [__] at the time and
then so taking this and I was in this
Alleyway with a bunch of smokers at like
he was smoking cigarettes and then I I
genuinely thought I just I'm only
telling a story because it feels fitting
for what you've said and the fact that
there's so much Batman talk
I I thought I was in Gotham City and
that's like the criminals and I thought
like Catwoman was crawling on the wall
oh it's so good but you gotta understand
I'm not like Batman in Gotham City I'm
just a regular
I'm a civilian in primary so does it go
well for me
I'm just Indian I gotta walk home to the
Narrows later
of Gotham
um I was just shouting at my friends
like you gotta call me a [__]
[__] and they were just laughing at
me are you still friends with these
people yeah yeah yeah
I was the one this was the choice it's a
real bonding experience oh man that's
good um in the chat don't feel about the
eggshell it's okay as long as you care
enough to try and get the pronouns right
I think that's what matters it's a great
example of the thing I was talking about
though people get so mad and it's like
we're effort is put in to do better
that's what life's about is effort and
it's so exhausting and people are like
they don't care enough about pronouns
and thus they don't care about people we
tried we're doing the work well and if
you screw it up don't don't get div
don't don't get defensive like I just
just be like oh okay I'll I'll update
you know and I think I think that effort
that openness is what counts I'm gonna
change my pronouns every two weeks and
if you guys
uh Stacy's Mom
mom
uh favorite members of the bat family
other than Batman I might have no
particular order Cassandra Kane Damon
Wade and Jason Todd mine is specifically
specifically Dick Grayson his Nightwing
love him yep yep yep yep that's my
favorite great call easily is Alfred
part of the bat family
no
you're a slave Alfred
you are an employee
yeah you do not come to the family
Christmas party get a W-9 at the end of
the year
uh dick Grayson's a huge one for me uh
I'm a big fan of when they have like
less than 20 bat family members like I I
personally like it contained I like Dick
Grayson I like I like Tim Drake but I
don't like it when it's like part of 20
of them uh I I think that because Hunter
Kane is really interesting solo I like I
actually like her better by yourself I'm
a big Barbara Gordon guy I think Barbara
Gordon's my favorite next to Dick
Grayson I think she's great as Oracle
greatest Batwoman greatest just the
daughter of the commissioner she's got a
lot more depth to her than a lot of the
bat family uh and Alfred those are those
are my three Alfred Nightwing Barbara
Gordon
Mel Gibson Mel Gibson obviously Freedom
Malik Curry
thank you Malik
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
run to the super chats
I genuinely enjoy parts of this movie it
had an 8 out of 10 prior to the end and
he took it down to a six for me wow how
Wild like the actual land I just didn't
like how the okay okay you're talking
about the finale I just didn't like how
the importance of Supergirl and Batman
was basically wiped away
a little bit Yeah it kind of it wasn't
their Universe okay he went to that I'm
conflicted I I like the point of of you
can't save the both of us and also this
whole universe that you've created here
is doomed and you've got to let it all
go I like the purpose of that but also
yeah it is sort of like oh damn yeah no
the point of it is that
um it's not like they could keep this
universe intact with Superman it was
Supergirl and Batman around like they're
going to lose it's inevitable so he has
to go back in time and and you know uh
stomp his mom's facing
American History flash
let's go
strange man with sunglasses and a new
house tags on them just suddenly attacks
this woman he had to just murder his mom
intentionally I did find it interesting
that throughout the film they do dress
the different berries in yellow at Key
moments I do think that was going to be
plans for the sequel and like the Young
The Young Berry was in yellow very
pointedly yeah um but I don't know if
that was like you know just for Comic
fans like he or if it was going to be
any sort of like delivery you want to
get nothing
let's get nuts
with Deez Nuts Captain Kirk cashews do
you think machete will directing the
Brave and the Bold do you think we may
actually see a more comic animated
series accurate Batman that uses both
gadgets and detective skills Boston how
he handles Keenan yes I do that is a big
aspect that I am very much looking
forward to I think what he did not see
in the reverse flesh he's the same one
who's been people's chest I haven't seen
that thank you for I think you think you
saw reverse flash but I think he saw was
a yellow light
um
if you zoom into this one pixel the
reflection in his eye in the sequence
yes I completely think that will it'll
be one that differentiates itself from
Robert Pattinson's Batman but I am
excited to see a Batman with a little
bit more gadgets and gizmos and whatnot
I hope he slides down and pulling
changes I hope he has bat repellent
repellent that would be amazing uh I
think it'll be more fun but I but you
know like what we saw what he did with
even like the old school Gadget gizmos
that Michael Keaton had here even
bethleck out of old school exactly that
one gun that's what I mean if we I I
think there's a lot of potential for
what he can pull off and I think with
with uh James Gunn I feel like James
Gunn's going to be a really Hands-On I
feel like eventually there's going to be
one of these movies where step out of
what you don't remember let me direct it
let me direct it
sure I also like that The Flash movie
was like uh at the premiere it was
Hamada gun uh saffron like it was the
old guard and new guard and that feels
really Hands-On like unifying and Jim
Lee got promoted to the head of like DC
creative for all the comments a lot of
thank you to Zack Snyder too yeah there
was there was a lot of gratitude and Ben
Affleck was clapping very like I noticed
he like accelerated his clapping and I
was like that man's got a lot of respect
for Zack Snyder and it was cool to see
like that respect uh but I also think
that uh mushieri's going to be more able
to do what he wants without having to
make a sequel recall launching point in
ping Point like this one like this will
be his Batman and I think his love of
Batman is going to shine in a different
way and I think that keeping Matt Reeves
Batman will allow this to be more fun
spirited and a lot of people have been
wanting that from Batman for years like
since no one took over but he's like I
want to fun Batman I think with Reeves
now you can have the Duality and
dichotomy of both
in the next voice one okay I keep
missing that last d word going off of
Malik's last one he said I genuinely
enjoyed parts of this movie I had an 8
out of 10 prior to the end and he took
it down to six for me I just didn't like
how the importance of Supergirl Batman
was basically wiped away what he
continued saying was I get that they use
their inevitable deaths to show Barry
you can't change the path but it just
didn't sit right with me I do agree that
there needed to be especially for
Supergirl there needed to be a little
bit of an extra umph
because at least with Batman they made
the concerted effort to show like hey he
at least got something out of this
but but uh Supergirl is just like I'm
MAC I'm dead
two two lines from the actual film yeah
it's a very Shakespearean that one scene
I agree I agree with you I'm not I'm
going to disagree with you on that but
man I just think Sasha Kai is great
truly so much president presence and she
is um
she is not ugly she was in Kirk is here
she was outside the screening I went to
in bright silver pantalism
to the super attacks what do you think
about Wally being our new Flash for the
DCU
do it and have Ezra Miller play Wally
and they use the comic reasoning of
Barry going missing in a crisis which
Wally could narrate her to the audience
Allah the Batman opening oh that's great
who could play Wally West yeah she'd
like more
ten years ago would have been perfect
um what do you think um that's mean
I'm sorry time happens the amount of
people that got mad at me for saying
that like the Harrison Ford Indiana
Jones used his age appropriately for
stunts they were like let's ages like a
70 year old man moving is impressive
like the the it's just it time happens
it's not ageism to Just note
life happening the the embracing of age
I did not know the Indiana Jones fandom
was so toxic anyway uh back to this
toxicity uh I think that uh Wally West
is the right move because I think they
made Barry Allen kind of a mix between
Wally West and Barry Allen I think Barry
Allen is much more Golden Age hero he's
got like more that Hal Jordan quality I
think Grant Gustin plays him like 80
Barry 20 Wally I think that it's the
inverse with esri plays a much more
jokey he almost plays impulse but I
think Wally West would be a good
um uh eye line for the audience in the
Justice League someone that you can
attach to someone that you can
um really connect with as a fun spirited
character that is super kinetic and high
energy and I think that's going to be
important with how big the Justice
League is going to be under James Gunn
yeah I agree man I agree you know I
still feel like Grant Gustin is the
definitive flash for me
especially Barry yeah I think Grant
gustin's is perfect in that role no
matter where that show Falls or Grant
Gustin was consistent Flash Gordon is
the best one
[Music]
did we catch up on them when we skipped
what did we catch them I know we
scrolled up okay there was one we moved
over to get the second part I was just
making sure we got the person in between
yeah okay cool stop it
okay just checking it Steve Stevie the
geek you
oh it's this one
oh
he's that super chat's huge yeah see now
I can hear it it's a good transition
movie is
plus however it's a love letter to DC
Universe also I'm really happy you
consider Snyder cut Cannon battle up
pause for enough and reversing time
I feel like there was one line in there
that made me question if they were
trying to say it's a continuation of
both oh
I bet uh Walter Hamada was there being
like to cut those lines
cut that [__] out man it's everything
it's nothing
but whatever you want it to be it's
whatever the box office says it is the
shark doesn't like me
I mean I think it worked as a Snyder
Sequel and I and I do think it was
definitely a love letter to the Snyder
cut and it definitely felt like all
those odd sequence felt like it was
paying homage in a really nice way oh
definitely sure I don't have to work I
think intention
I think attention intention intention
there's intention sure also uh Cameron
Schism uh yeah enjoy that Jonas awful
reaction appreciate you uh checking that
out
and just finishing the episode
all right guys let's probably go to the
next one and Christian unpronounceable
we're at that point in the Stream
[Music]
the G fuel must rise
super chats huge okay so like the scene
of Barry phasing through what was like
my favorite Christian and pronounceable
says looked exactly like I imagined it
for decades those were some damn good
phasing scenes that's where reverse
flash was is he was in the molecules of
the wall he was hiding there was a
yellow molecule
yeah it was also smart because you kind
of get some you get Like An Origin tale
of Barry without getting an origin tale
of berry yeah I like that you know like
some of the explaining and at least the
alluding to and there's been a whole
television show dedicated to the flash
so I don't feel like we need like a full
odd flash reaction hey Spider-Man
reaction flash of origin tail you know
um one's the Beyond the Sea reaction
going up I don't know no one's watching
our Black Mirror videos and they take
too much work so let's be on the scene
it's not gonna upload any of them
anymore
so Galindo
you want to get nothing
let's get nuts oh it's super chats
congrats on the con
thanks John I'm so excited I enjoyed the
film laughed a lot cried at the end love
desert's performance Becky and supercal
and seeing the cage so funny when Barry
tries running in the lab no power
spaghetti thoria his theory is Chef kiss
great summation damn that is everything
everything I like some good [__] uh
right there well done
that should be a Rotten Tomatoes
capsules tattoo encapsulate everything I
liked about the movie I'd be like yup
all right here super Kanye [__]
did like the action though
oh yeah
I'm glad it exists that's my big thing
in this movie I'm really glad it felt it
felt like they loved flash for me yeah
Bronson the right wolf what are your
thoughts on Lou Ferrigno as the
Incredible Hulk well I'm glad you asked
in this stream it's an important time to
talk about it what are your thoughts on
every plus now Dana as the Incredible
Hulk well I think Lou Ferrigno was the
definitive Hulk still to this day he is
what are your thoughts on Eric badass
Incredible Hulk I think in 20 years they
should have him
they will because you know they will
actually deserves it
I wanted Norton to cameo in secret Wars
I liked Eric Bana I loved Ed Norton he's
still like Hulk to me I love Mark
ruffalo's take but he's definitely like
the team take kind of like how Tom
Holland is the team Spider-Man I
consider like Marco flow that and Andrew
Garfield to me as Spider-Man just like
Edward to me is better as a Hulk
Incredible Hulk for Derek ban is one of
those movies that whenever I look back
on it I'm like man there was some cool
[__] in there that I feel like is not
recognized enough and then whenever I
put it on I'm like this movie's so
boring
you're like wait are they right or am I
right past me
every every time like when I think about
it I'm like man there's some cool [__]
and whenever I'm watching like guys
I've seen the Incredible Hulk I have not
seen Hulk I love that like Ed Norton's
Twitchy
why is it not on the list I
was just reminded that it exists
but now it is yeah it's artsy and he did
I I remember people's praising his comic
book-esque transitions
I think if I divide the viewing
experience up by like two separate
showings I think it's enjoyable you
gotta pace yourself yeah sure it takes a
while to get going
Ismail Montoya let's see if we can wrap
this up in four minutes guys we got this
I would love to see Robert Patterson's
Batman and his Batmobile in this movie
Dare I said it yeah I mean that would be
that would be awesome
I hope he gets I can't wait for Batman
too the Batman 2 I'm one of my most
anticipated movies I'm like I'm glad I'm
glad it's staying separate so they can
do the fun stuff looks great yeah who
hears Veil for the support my friend Tim
kogan
thank you Kim Kong for being here
prediction Blue Beetle post credit is
BB's Universe slamming into the gun
verse and that's a BB could be the first
here when Legacy be the first movie
gun did say that that would be the first
official movie in the DCU right on on uh
Rosenbaum Trail so he was like no no
this one counts yeah I think they
probably did some reshoots where they
took out any references and they also
probably made the universe kind of a
catch-all like I imagine it's going to
be kind of a clean slate movie where
it's like the 90s comic movies where it
doesn't have a ton of references to a
universe that way later they can include
Blue Beetle but this movie doesn't
include the other stuff I thought this
one was supposed to be the reset
he said this would be the reset he flat
out said in the announcement of when he
announced like 45 properties and he said
the flash is our reset film but then
often items I don't get yeah I don't get
the impression this is the reset film I
feel like with Aquaman coming out it's
basically like I thought there would be
something at the end I was like okay
it's been reset right I'm more like I
got questions well no I think he's
establishing there's separate universes
the Multiverse been established so
everything else we experience is trapped
in some other units he's just chilling
hanging out with George
but he's got his dad that's nice all
right
yeah that that I'm still kind of trying
to piece that the whole Blue Beetle is
the first character Superman well like
if there's different the third act has
those different orbs yeah so this is an
orb we haven't seen yet like if there's
those different planetoids like we're on
one of those I just because like I don't
know
Barry run to the super chats the heavy
900 it was odd to reshoot the ending
with Clooney when we saw the set picks
of Keating that same car but doesn't
that make it a surprise
because you're expecting Michael keated
Rye I understand it was their way of
closing off the universe as a joke but
it was strange damn b900 no one is going
to deny the fact that it's strange and
it confuses the audience and raises
questions however it's George Clooney
and we love the Clone sir man he's been
so much more respected because he's done
so much more like cooler work after
Batman and Robin he's won Oscars man for
acting people forget that he won an
acting Oscar siriana siriana man he got
his name Nails torn off siriano also
broke his back and had to go to therapy
for years because the traumatic
headaches boring so uh he got serious
and then he's good luck Chuck he won the
uh yes
trying to get that sequel Yeah man so I
didn't actually
I thought it made sense I thought it was
a great way to tie it all up for me it's
like a classic button of this kind of
story exactly to me and he has a classic
George Clooney line what's the matter
with you it's like what George Clooney
would say I also feel like the joke of
the the whole George Clooney ever being
Batman got beautifully wrapped up it was
like closure Charles Smith
he says for all the praise Ezra gets
thank you for the Super Chat his
performance was
uh like Ave of average maybe AV is that
like mid is that like Javier Rod his
obvious scream sexual insecurity well
they established that he knows his name
is a full-grown adult and has not had
sex he knows that it exists it's a part
of the character I don't think his
references average at all he's played
two very different people at himself
personally yeah
no I thought they did a Excelsior job
I can also type the seven letter word
all the way so I guess I just who am I
there's a hey they gave us money hey use
the word nice Ave an Avenue nice that's
what I say to all these brand deals and
he's back put me through hell
and yes he does continue to say to save
any misconstruencies I mean to say as
replace barriers if the character is
sexually insecure has a lot of feminine
mannerism this is why I was a feisty
because I don't know like what's wrong
with having fundament mannerisms like
what's the problem that's yeah well
it just seems like a judgment and that's
not like that's sexual mannerisms I want
to see a movie with Ezra Miller Jesse
Eisenberg
there is a guy on the internet
does Michael Saratoga
what do you want to watch tonight
incredible yeah it sounds just like it's
crazy I forget who the guy is but he's
not just like them yeah I think he plays
him on the Spectrum more than like
effeminently don't be racist I also
don't like I don't see someone having
fun memories as like a deterrent to the
character I think it's like a strength
to make him unique sure sure say
whatever [__] you want again that
way you get hit up yes say whatever soy
koi yeah for yourself
is here yes
I have sexual freedom and fluidity they
should be one thing only one I just saw
the blackening which is really good I
haven't seen anything about it but
actually other than I saw when I went to
check the flashes Rotten Tomato score
with the black and it had a much better
score the best joke of any film I saw
this weekend was in it Sanctuary was
very good flash was a seven out of ten
for me blackening maybe that'll be a
video on demand release by the way guys
for anyone who's like gives us crap
about when we watch something on video
and demand here
um Studios love when you buy a video
and and uh they they've had there's a
reason why they release it so soon after
because it is a massive profit margin
for them uh so yeah are we not in the
theaters doing it no but the studios are
not going to complain when you're buying
horses we don't download them and watch
it we buy them and watch it that's how
we do it char Charles Smith to save any
misconstruances I mean oh yeah we read
that we already yeah you don't get two
reads no this is you'll get two reads
we'll have a second wait was there one
before him there because there was a
middle one we got the Charleston okay
I see it I see it now
thank you trying to keep three people on
track is impossible here like are you
including yourself like the third person
there's dreams totally yes it's hard to
keep three of us on track to finish on
time
hold on a second everyone
all right
run Barry run to the super chats not
watching Superman loaded three no one
cares about our reactions or season four
that's just being lit yeah it was gonna
get a lower budget too yeah
imagine the post-credits scene with
Affleck telling Barry to find them
setting up the future crisis film Hamada
wanted yeah I think one of the original
post-credit scenes was actually Ben
Affleck he gets he calls Barry and he's
like Barry I'm trapped somewhere else
yeah yeah I heard that too
um then the mid credit scene with Barry
seeing Wonder Woman Aquaman and
Supergirl so that would still
established that like oh we got another
one yeah that would have been cool I
would have liked that I would I I would
have been neat there was also apparently
a courtroom scene with like the whole
Justice League really yeah apparently
like everyone including Supergirl and uh
Michael King the Batman were like in the
courthouse but I I don't know how that
would have worked that's why I care
about Barry's dad we're very invested
this man we loved him we're here to see
that Justice is served
we know this stuff
Gracie and Ryan yes
uh Joey Chas um comic movies aren't all
flopping Guardians did great and across
spider-verse was like number two
animated film of all time it's okay to
be wrong just don't be loud about it all
caps is done for you yeah rounding down
for all the delays I just I'm just fine
just showing my appreciation for my
three guys I didn't get a plan holy crap
guys do it do it do it
you want to get nothing
let's get nuts
yeah yeah we'll watch Superman Lois
now I can watch it on the big TV with
the lights off it's gonna be great
um just showing my appreciation for
three gorgeous Bays oh my God it's Logan
Marshall Green in the thumbnail dude so
sexy I know
shocker I know you cared about not a lot
of people it's just it did like I'm
feeling it what I'm feeling with black
mirror right now like God so many
so much work put into this and no one's
watching
yeah and then I hired then like for the
second one it's like hired prepper for
it I was like oh
we're out to some editing money back
so it's happened so it just happens
sometimes though still enjoying the show
but you know like I can't do that for 15
episodes guys
but with Black Mirror the difference is
we managed to get a lot of patrons from
it I'll offset some of that you know
it's got to be It's gotta be the middle
ground we gotta love what we're doing
and also financially Justified at the
same time not like like oh we're not
making a 50 profit on this it's like no
it's like it's a lot of times
broke enough for you you don't want to
only always break even but if you're a
cons like for 15 weeks
but if you know you're making like a
little bit of money you're like all
right cool that's good
gotta pay people around here man
he's he's paid for these yeah by the
minute he's paid for these technically
there's a way to do a minute factor out
here
cam plays oh my God a good one you want
to get nothing
[Applause]
do I read before the original miles run
uh so there's a run called Ultimate
Spider-Man that leads to the Ultimate
Spider-Man that is Miles Morales so
Ultimate Spider-Man starts in the year
2000s written by Byron Michael Bendis
and illustria Mark Bagley so look for
Ultimate Spider-Man number one by Venice
and Bagley from the year 2000's got red
panels on the side it's him swinging so
that is the start of that run you can
read volume one which is one through
Thirteen the issue 13 is one of the best
Spider-Man titles ever if you like it
keep going but that'll give you just a
basis to get to the mile stuff and then
when he comes into the universe it's in
Jonathan Hickman's Secret Wars which is
the 2015 run all you need to read for
the Jonathan Hickman secret orrs really
is the Jonathan nickman Fantastic Four
then his secret Wars which folds
everything into our universe the
incursion event of The Secret Wars that
Jonathan wrote was basically to allow
miles into r616 Universe from his 1610
universe so start with the 1610 Ultimate
Spider-Man get to the 616 Fantastic Four
then read The Secret Wars that fold it
all in and then you can read uh miles
from there and pretty much get the
context for everything that he is
koi that was really impressive thanks
man I don't know if people have ever
pointed this out about you but you talk
fast and efficiently and you use good
words and you're great at summarizing
your points and you can do that all like
off The Dome and I know the things which
is good but I don't think anyone ever
says that about you no no
that's a great point
[Laughter]
yeah buddy yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the
flash Dan v900 oh he's got two equating
to a 10. run Barry run to the super
chats The Flash coming out after across
the spider versus no favors like
everything ever all wants coming up for
Multiverse of Madness yeah I feel like
everything everywhere all at once affect
well see it wasn't as big though yeah I
remember everything I remember rolling
once was still like like a little yeah
so not everyone had been seeing it yet
but those who did see it were greatly
affected by their experience by the
Multiverse and Madness
um I completely get it with that I don't
really feel that it's I feel like
they're still very different in in what
they're setting out to do so that I'm
not watching it comparing it going you
see spider-verse did this I thought
spider verse did it better and here's
what they should have done with spot
like I actually I feel like this whole
stream we haven't really even compared
to the spider I don't know it's the
first time we mentioned it was when I
said it was doing well we haven't
compared it right whereas like with with
everything ever all at once and and
Multiverse there are so many any
similarities what they want to do that
you're like oh yeah so yeah I mean I I
can see kind of like I just saw a
Multiverse movie I don't want to see
another comic book Multiverse I can see
that but you know my biggest thing was
Guardians was so good and then across
the spider verse was somehow even better
so flash just had a tricky like that was
more of an issue than the Multiverse
issue Heather you are so loyal to us on
our patreon do not send us a Super Chat
and your super sticker did go through
what I was what I will do is send you my
uh bank account information correct so
you can sell me or wire me a thousand
dollars though that would be preferred
honestly yes kind of because that'll
just be a private exchange
did you just get it who's calling you
the Disney public it's a Disney
publicist is calling me Marshall's like
why aren't you here so yeah there's a
hundred people here it's my birthday
away for you we should talk about a DC
movie longer for the Disney certain
people had their pitch from Australia
for Flash and small to Cammy I was due
early due to Ezra Miller my favorite
reference was Keaton asking for the
weight
the weight oh yeah when he's like how
much do you weigh which is a reference
to Batman 89 when he asks uh her how
much he weighs to use the the same list
oh yeah yeah he uses it as a bomb here
for that lift that was a really well
done reference I love that reference
because if you don't even get the
reference right away it still works
because he's trying to estimate how much
power he needs
yeah and if you do get it then you're
like seeing that this Batman has evolved
like it's genius I I was really
impressed that's a really well that's a
very very well done
um reference
so yeah okay but we did get stickers
John uh-huh yeah all right guys koi I'm
running down for you by two and a half
hours okay
all right accept these terms
and conditions don't worry koi you did a
Transformers review for 15 minutes I
rounded up to an hour
I'm generous that video did well not
well enough
you know you're generous when you go I'm
generous yeah I'm the number one point
out everything I get done around here
kind of guy
huh look what I oh Vince look what I do
no one quite as a way for compliments
he's the kind of guy he's gonna wait to
point out what he's done first
you know did it shut up John oh boy me
shut up I I need to be complimented
Supreme
is bringing out the worst
that's right man
now that I could put my elbows at this
table I've adopted a whole new attitude
another hour next stream is going to be
all albums just like it's here to be
like hanging out let me tell you [__]
something you know this is long-haired
this is
a longer table though we do because this
frankly is wild no that's good because
that'll keep your energy as the central
like table energy and then we're like
kind of hanging and then we're only half
relaxed we're like 80s kids just like
chilling in the poster that way it's
perfectly proportionate and symmetrical
all right we did everything we had our
gear sticker guys we've done it we've
done it all we got the last Envy
I know yes we did I read it you'll pay
attention to me it was early all right
the weight the whole thing about the
weight we did a whole commentary about
the weight sorry I got just because
I'm still leaning forward so you're
happy how many times have you guys been
like do we do this and I'm like yeah we
just did a whole thing about it but
there were a few times where we hadn't
that's true yes and then we did them and
we got nervous though
so it's worth the march in the mirror I
think it's a try
no this is how we should in the Stream
fighting
[Laughter]
who's winning
right yeah don't even like little things
off camera you're like I'm just turning
this camera off this is done
you're exhausted Diamond guy I keep
going forever I've had like three 14 to
15 hour days in a row I can keep this is
nothing compared to that
so stop yelling at me Dinah guy you're
getting defensive
plug the interview I haven't had to
apologize to a couple people what
interview the one that I did for the
thing that dropped coin review the
director of secret invasion you said the
men remind you and I didn't know who
okay now I know we're ending with the
sex joke there it is
nobody is winning
true all right Jean also check out it's
okay check out Gene's new Prince book
all right before we end check out Gene's
book
okay
so I don't like have a joke it's not
like my Captain Hook joke you know like
cat how did Captain Hook have you heard
my cat no great jokes how did Captain
Hook die
he wiped his ass with the wrong hand
s they're a classic now I really just
have like a sketch idea of what my flash
sex joke is I've loved in the Injustice
game you know that fight maneuver when
um he goes like he like goes in the
speed force he does a bunch of punches
and elected their whole body and then it
goes into real time mode and then it
then you see their opponent go like like
all at once I want to see that for like
a scene when you know he has to rush to
get to work and Iris is like oh but
Barry why don't we just do it really
fast and he's like I don't have time but
he's like but I could still satisfy you
then he goes into the speed force and it
does her in like you know like 500
positions just super duper fast gets out
of it and then she's like I thought we
were gonna oh and then she just feels
freaked all the sensations
everywhere just just like pops into like
orgasmic to smoking a cigarette right
away and people wonder how Barry gets
Iris West yeah she's alone she knows
terribly you know that if Clark Kent has
like Kryptonite condoms he's got flash
Lube there's some scientific lubricant
that can withstand the friction right
speed he's got it anyway guys he's a
scientist my um flash sex idea all right
that's good that's even weird to place
down the stream than fighting
which I like thank you guys so much for
being here leave a like on your way out
appreciate everyone who contributed to
our super chats and stream labs in all
sincerity thank you John again for uh
being here Awesome everything everyone
wants it's amazing in here that's great
I had to give that should have I should
have ended it there good joke koi thank
you for bringing in the a game here
um there's a reason you are brought here
so often now specifically to bring your
comp acknowledge to reaction videos like
the extraction 2 couldn't keep it
sincere I'm sorry nope
whatever I don't even know how to take a
compliment that's true
so if I don't receive one that's I don't
know how to give one I understand it now
thank you guys again